Hello, hello!
Today is a special day because we are playing, finally
playing the one Sonic game that I've been dying to play for
so fucking long.
Shadow the Hedgehog!
Some people were very confused what game this was because it
did say Shadow the Hedgehog reloaded.
So for those who are wondering what game this is, this is
literally the original uh yeah the the edge lord himself the
the very oh is my mic sound different oh whoops sorry this
is my recording oh i was on my recording setup sorry guys um
i had to record something for the maid cafe uh uh thing that
is gonna be there for next week um that's why i i didn't
realize i was still on that so i was recording that earlier
um so yeah recorded session for it um yeah it's for the maid
cafe the pre-recorded by the way for those who are wondering
about the maid cafe we are opening more slots i think in two
hours right at 7 p.m um so in two hours uh there will be
more tickets for the live session and the pre-recorded
session with me and mint that's gonna be out in two hours
i'll post the link to it too real quick um but but but but
but but so here is let me do the ticketed and get you guys
to the event too right here but but but but but but but but
but i think this is it yeah so in two hours there will be
more tickets uh coming out um for the may cafe that is in i
believe this is la right i don't know anything about america
uh i'm trying where the fuck is that california is that la
even the ass was like these are the only places i know in
america i'm like is is that la uh yeah okay nice okay i got
that right i was like la is in california right yeah okay so
that's in la uh so for anyone that will be there oh my gosh
next week oh my god i'm so out of it it's actually in next
week
next week on this uh when on the 6th to 13th um this or sex
sorry second to 13th sorry uh i don't i'm so ahead of i'm so
professional i know i'm so well versed in all the things i'm
supposed to be in uh very up to date obviously um uh so
there's that um what else i want to say um oh yes so
Hedgehog Reloaded is actually is is the original shadow the
uh, I was gonna say edge lord Shadow you know fuck it shadow
the edge lord uh GameCube game but is a modded version of
the game where it makes it less I guess like less fucked up
less tilting the play because obviously for some reason
they've only made one game for shadow despite how popular he
is um because apparently when the game first came out it
wasn't that good who would have thought apparently one of
the issues is that he doesn't go very fast which is you know
crazy to think about because Sonic games the whole premise
is that you gotta go fast and one thing they fixed is that
Yeah, it's basically a quality of life.
They basically made quality of life changes.
In the Shadow the Edge Lord reloaded.
There were a lot of performance issues.
But the one thing, the one thing that I was looking forward
to the most for this game, like I said, I wanted to play
this game for a very, very long time, even when I was in
Corpa.
But the reason why I couldn't play it is because for some
reason they never remastered this game I don't know why is
it because he had a gun is it because like he is it because
he had a not just a gun but a submachine gun so they were
like maybe we shouldn't remaster it there's no way to
actually play this game on modern on PC until now and I had
I was looking up like how to play and a lot of people were
like oh yeah you gotta play the reloaded version because
they fixed all the issues of the original games I was like
okay um so this is the reloaded version so all the gripes
you had when you when this game first came out when you were
a little kid um look no further they apparently fixed all of
that but still kept the edge because he is the greatest life
form um also a life update um okay I forgot to tell you guys
this story But basically, I was shopping for groceries.
I think like a week or two ago, I was shopping for groceries
like two weeks ago.
And it was like, you know, two weeks ago, it was around like
the 10th to 15th timeline.
This is very important, by the way.
This is very important.
So, and then I decided I was just like, you know what?
want to buy some string cheese i haven't had mozzarella
string cheese in so long oh i feel like a child today and
i'm craving some mozzarella string cheese so it was a good
good choice from doki too good choice from past doki because
every day i had one stick of string cheese because i forgot
how addicted i was eating mozzarella string cheese um
because when i was in middle school i my mom would always
get me mozzarella string cheese and i would have it like i
would have one stick every day because I was just so
addicted to it it's just the good shit anyway so after a
week plus of eating you know one stick of string cheese
every day I finally decided to look at the expiration date
because I was like oh you know what how when do these expire
I gotta make sure I'm not eating expired cheese and the
expiration date on it was no 5th and do you remember when I
bought the string cheese I was like how is this expired
before I even bought the cheese so technically I've been
eating expired cheese the entire time and I was just like I
was like how is this still in the grocery store.
I didn't think I had to check the bag of string cheese
before I purchased it.
Because you would assume those would, they would have not
even been purchasable.
Because I purchased it after it expired.
Neglected cheese.
And it's not, it was, I took the first pack.
I didn't like scrounge at the back and took the last pack.
I took the, I took the first pack i saw i so so i i've ate
i've been eating expired string cheese for like at least
eight days straight before i realized that this expired
before i even like fucking paid for it
um so yeah no this was just a little life update because now
i realize i'm i can't i didn't realize i you know what okay
so the thing is i would look for like milk and stuff i'll
look at expiration for milk because like milk and eggs
because like that's like more important to me but i would
never thought that there would be something like i don't
know i guess i'm so fucking naive to think that like what's
in the store will not be expired by then you know like
Because I'm like I bought it a week after it expired So
that's why I was I was so confused.
No, it says expired.
It's not So So I was just like I don't know I felt like you
would it would still be fucking purchasable if it's already
past the date But yeah
so so that's a life update now i need it now i know that i
have to make sure everything is now i gotta make sure that
everything um everything is like the correct date before i
buy stuff uh angriest thank you for super chat thank you
thank you grocery store tech always grab the item from the
back of the stock because they usually have the furthest
expiration date they use super you.
Gus, thank you.
The ultimate life form uses guns because guns are the
ultimate weapon, not that nerd magic pew pew shit.
I mean, all Sonic does is just he jumps on people.
That's like so fucking, what's the word?
That's so prehistoric, you know, like get on with the time,
Sonic.
Here, have a gun.
That's way too retro, bro.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got my ticket.
I'm super excited to see you.
I'm in to perform.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Broken Bond.
Super Chat.
Thank you.
No problem.
Hey guys.
Thank you.
A super chat.
A pump action submachine gun.
Uh, Alan, thank you.
Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Today's my birthday.
And as per our contract, I have to throw money at you.
Fifth year in a row and hoping for many more.
Thank you, Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday dear Alan Happy
birthday to you Happy birthday Alright guys Now it's shadow
time It's edgelord time Alright Okay Okay I didn't expect
Okay alright shadow Wonder why they never made a sequel or a
remastered Do I even have a sound guide today Alright Boom
okay bang I don't know I read this is amazing I don't know
why Sega were too much of a coward to remaster what they're
too they're cowards to not remaster
this oh my god yeah that's an SMG right there oh my god he
even knows how he has a license bro sonic doesn't even have
a license license to kill he's so cool i don't understand
how this game was not popular it has everything how is this
game not as popular as sonic 06
he doesn't need a license the pump action MVP five
you're right he doesn't need a license look at him fucking
running pathetic imagine running when you can just shoot
your gun
that's right you had
Shadow, what the fuck?
Did you shoot Sonic?
What?
Like, I got just that pistol right behind him.
He's so cool, guys.
Oh, my God.
He's so fucking cool.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, I am what I am.
Oh.
Oh, I can listen to in-game music here.
Okay, wait, exit.
Where's Y?
Oh, there it is.
Uh, English, uh, speak.
Okay, yeah, I forgot.
This game doesn't have, like, audio balance.
Alex, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum.
God, he's so fucking cool.
Why did they never make a sequel for this?
Hello, Shadow.
the latinas ain't
the same he didn't have a gun in the in his sequel it
doesn't count if he has no gun i don't consider it a real
sequel i up the game volume maria maria who am i who am i
my name is shadow and this is my story
we shot a kid holy fuck this is related to maria look how
pathetic they are i don't have time for it
hashtag not my problem where the fuck is this guy What?
I don't even remember who I am.
How do you know I'm shadow?
And what are you talking about?
Yeah, he's like, what the fuck are you talking about?
Just what was that all about?
If he says he knows the truth about who I am, then like it
or not, I have to believe that.
Yes, listen to the devil.
Surely he's not lying.
to get those chaos it's the double from the bible i
mean he is the double of course he's gonna leave explosions
i mean if i was what the okay okay we're going straight in
um um all right time time to go and fulfill this promise i i
don't even know the controls am i doing anything i'm just
free falling Okay, all right, that's cool.
All right, I'm running it.
Okay, X.
Okay, I feel like I could go faster.
Like, I don't.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I gotta figure this out.
I have a feeling that I'm supposed to be able to go a little
faster.
Oh, there you go.
All right, there you go.
I figured it out.
Okay, why am I not going forward?
Okay, that's fine.
okay okay sonic oh shit bye sonic i okay wait okay is that
not x am i not pressing x right now oh my god what are the
controls what are the control wait did i find my controls
while i okay give me a sec i gotta figure this out all right
Controls apparently.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Alright, there we go.
I figured it out.
Hello, sir.
The X-Bug lets me spin-dash and perform other actions.
Alright, sir.
I figured it out.
And finally, how do I talk to you?
Sir, how do I talk to you?
Sir, I want to talk to you.
Are you, can I talk to you?
I press X to love.
Let's see this.
Touch the question.
I have no question mark button.
Okay, let's see.
I have I binded everything.
What else am I missing?
Oh, is he dead?
No, see he's raising his arm.
Look.
He's Guys, he's raising his arm.
There's no way he's dead.
All right, fuck it.
I'll kill him.
All right, hello, Sonic.
Sonic?
What?
You on top?
Okay, bye.
I guess he doesn't.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Am I not shooting you?
Okay, we gotta go fast.
Please, just, I think I just need a gun.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I don't know.
Is he a good guy?
Oh, that was his HP.
Okay, I'm figuring it out.
Guys, I need a gun.
Okay, I killed him.
We didn't see it.
Guys, he's not dead.
Oh, he has a gun.
Let's go.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we have to kill him.
him zero in and attack enemies by pressing the a bar in the
middle of a jump okay now now that's why that's that's what
i like let's go what the heck is hq doing i can swap the
weapon on here
oh wait he has a gun too oh okay it's okay it's okay i just
got one one ring.
Okay, okay, it's not okay.
It's okay.
I'll hit the man.
He's easier to kill.
Oh my god!
Okay, he is not easier to kill.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's okay.
He is easier to kill.
There you go.
Alright, I figured it out.
Now I have a gun.
Alright.
Guys, now I think I know why this game didn't get a sequel.
Okay.
I think I don't now.
I think it's getting pretty obvious why.
And this is the quality of life version.
A skill issue.
I'm a little concerned what the non-quality of life version
was like.
It's okay.
That sounds like a skill issue.
You're right, you're right.
It was a skill issue, guys.
How dare I tell perfection?
Alright, don't worry.
We can slowly go up.
Oh, nice shortcut.
Wait, what?
What am I supposed to do with this?
With this?
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, cool.
I'm not gonna go down.
Whether they like it or not.
Wee!
Oh my god, behold!
The ultimate power!
Oh, I'm so fast.
I am so fast right now.
Child, please, get down.
I repeat, this is not a grill.
That's right!
Oh, that's it.
Okay, that was a bit anticlimactic.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, where am I?
Oh!
How did I just happen to...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I went too fast.
That was on me.
That was on me, guys.
I went too fast.
Oh.
What's this?
I think I can use this.
I can try.
Oh my god.
I don't need a license for this.
What if I...
playing.
What is this game?
I don't know!
Shadow!
No!
I'm too fast!
I'm too fucking fast, Cash.
I can't help it!
GTA Edge Lord, let's go.
Do I even have a lifespan on this car?
Oh my god, this car is so fucking strong.
I don't know.
I don't even know what the fuck is happening.
We found it.
We got the chaos emerald.
There you go.
She's not playing.
Once I find all of the emeralds, then I'll find the truth.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
We got two chaos emeralds.
Since you're playing Silent Fan News, Mad Record, Project
06, it's Sonic 06, but good.
James, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
So they use super chat.
They shadowed a headshot.
Hit and run.
I... Yeah, E for excellent, guys.
E for excellent.
E for easy.
The black aliens have hit six major cities around the world.
And every city is reporting significant damage and
casualties.
Oh my god.
Surely it's not my fault, right?
The defense system.
Downtown Westopolis has been almost...
Completely destroyed.
Unconfirmed sources have also reported This is the original
game, but better.
They did quality of life changes.
It's crazy that this is the quality of life change.
Then kill them all.
But, sir, isn't Shadow on our side?
I gave you an order, soldier.
He's evil and he's the enemy.
Just because I'm edgy, I'm evil.
Oh, guys, come on.
That's racist.
You're mine.
and I have my rights to bear arms.
This is America.
I'll have two now.
You've deliberately disobeyed me, Shadow.
No one tells me what to do.
I have my own reasons for collecting the Chaos Emeralds.
You really don't understand the situation here, do you?
Perhaps Professor Gerald has done more to your memory than I
imagine.
You know who I am?
You know about Maria?
Strange that you don't remember.
Your maker.
I have a father?
Silence.
The ramifications of your disobedience will be severe.
You're not American.
You don't know that.
My creator was American.
And so by proxy, Shadow is also American.
I was made in America.
Where am I?
USA USA Whoa, I guess I underestimated his powers He was
made in space You don't know that he lost his memory
I don't remember this place.
Oh, I'm so fast.
Yeah Oh my god.
Sonic has nothing on me.
Look how fast I am as I slowly fall down.
I like how like they try to talk to me.
Oh wait, it's Knuckles.
Hit, hit, hit, hit, hit, hit.
Quick grab a gun, Knuckles.
It's the only way.
Wait, what?
I'm trying.
Wait, how did you jump?
Oh there.
Alright, there you go.
Knuckles.
Why are you using knuckles?
Just grab a gun there everywhere.
Alright, wait, wait.
Boom.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh, alright.
Sucked up.
We're sucked up by the cyclone.
Wait, where are we now?
Oh, God, we're so fast.
Loop the loop.
That's right.
Truly the perfect life for.
Oh, shit!
What are you guys doing with a sword?
That's for pussies!
Wait, I gotta grab the gun.
Oh, no, wait.
It's heat seeking.
Wait.
Gun.
Oh, shit!
He cheated!
He hit behind!
Wait, I want this.
This has more ammo.
Grab the sword.
Why get a sword when I have bullets?
What the fuck is a sword gonna do for me, guys?
When there is guns!
Oh shit.
I should have shot all of it off.
Going to...
Going to Wicked now.
That sword makes you look cool.
Oh my god, shadow, please.
Right here you go.
Apparently in the original game, you had to kill everyone.
Like...
Oh, whoops, sorry.
In the original, like the non-reloaded version, you would
have to kill every single enemy.
to progress so like yeah this is why we're playing the
reloaded no don't say that no no we don't can i kill him oh
i killed it oh that's oh that's awkward oh that's awkward
it's okay i might have actually used my entire machine gun
on it what's this
only for oh i don't know what i did what happened Oh my god.
Oh my god.
And it makes me do all...
Okay, there you go.
It makes me go back to the beginning.
Oh, there's good and evil paths?
Watch out.
Alright.
Slow and steady in my Sonic game.
Do I just destroy it?
What the fuck do I do?
I do is this how do I destroy it guys what do I do oh okay
whatever I don't care anyway no just touch I did oh no I'll
leave oh it's activated oh oh I just touch it and go okay I
got it oh shit it's okay it's okay I'm okay I don't
understand!
No!
Take me back!
No, not again!
Sweet!
I don't...
Why?
Why does the kid take you back?
Okay.
Alright, let's grab this and leave.
Alright, here we go.
Guys, you don't understand.
I think... I think sometimes he goes too fast.
Oh my god.
God oh my god thank God okay we made it you're here forever
okay oh how do I get there I know hello regular people wait
there is something here what's this how How do I get this?
Wait, how do I break this, guys?
Come on, give me!
Give me!
Oh, okay, I guess I don't get it.
Oh, it's a secret ring?
I don't know what that is.
I'm like, oh!
I don't know what that is, but oh!
Wait, I want the sword!
Give me the sword!
Oh shit!
Chop!
Oh my god, guys, the sword sucks.
I like the gun more.
Hello, here's another little thing.
Oh my god, you fucker!
Get out of here!
All right.
I think I actually prefer the gun more, but it's okay.
Activated another one?
Surely that's not gonna...
That's not a bad thing, right?
All right, oh Knuckles please help at least punch the ball
there for me Like what's the point of being there?
Three out of five eva Well, gotta keep going Wait, there's
another eva There's another evil thing up top his little
body would the sword oh shit wait i need to get the other
evil thing the pseudo co-op it's like so i don't get lonely
it's like those people like it's like those coffee shop
where you can uh drink with a little drink with a plushie so
you don't feel lonely all right let's grab that you still
haven't taken care of those aliens who stole it yay
envious thank you the super chat thank you thank you decide
so edgy you've been giving three missions turn on the gems
for the evil path kill 60 for good path and find chaos
emerald for neutral thank you the super chat thank you thank
you oh so like i can like go to like more evil ending i know
that oh there's mr president there's the white house mr
president we've received the report from the central
information agency our ground All right, let's try for an
evil path.
I didn't realize there's like different stages for different
paths.
I like how it's like non-descript flag.
We all know it's America.
Tell the commanding generals that the United Federation will
never surrender to terrorists.
Yes, Mr. President.
Sonic and my best friend, Shadow and Sonic.
Does he not keep a photo of his fucking family?
We must stand united to defend our world against these
invaders.
What about his family?
Me and my bestie.
That is his family.
His real family I wonder
if there are any chaos emeralds around here Yeah Are there?
Oh Maria?
Oh No!
Cringe!
When you remember the cringe memories That you're trying to
suppress Was then captured by those humans But from where?
Akira, yeah.
Oh, is there a gun in here?
Alright.
Oh my god, the military?
Wait, I was a genetic freak?
Wait, who's with me now?
Who are you?
Oh, it's Charmy the Bee!
Wait, what are you doing here?
I don't have friends!
I don't need your friends!
Is it?
I'm touching it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, that's gross.
I'm gonna touch it.
I'm not gonna listen to you.
You're a bee.
Oh, hey, look, I got a gun.
See, I told you.
Listening to you was a mistake.
Now I have a gun.
Ah, oh, what?
Oh.
Alright.
Yay!
Woo!
It was?
Where did it go?
Oh, is that the abacus thing?
Boo,
boo, boo, boo!
Oh, there's another gun!
Alright, I got reload.
Reload!
Where is your fucking...
to be this thing.
Reload!
What even is this?
Is this?
What does that do?
I like how this guy is just watching me.
I don't even know if he's supposed to be a bad person.
Alright, get...
Oh my god!
What the fuck is this?
Alright.
Oh shit, that's it.
That's all the ammo.
Okay, I thought I had more.
For some reason, it looks...
Looked like I had a lot of ammo.
I don't know why.
God damn it.
Okay.
I don't want a sword.
The sword sucks.
Can I grip that?
No, I can't.
Large gun, not large mag.
I can't believe it.
Lie to me.
Chop!
Oh, I can't chop it.
That sucks I'm gonna chop you.
Oh shit.
Okay.
No, that's cool.
That's cool All right, we gotta get out from here All right,
slide Sorry Charmy.
I don't know where the fuck to find your little disc things
Where where Charmy oh here We got one of the secret discs
Let's go!
Oh!
Be hard!
Oh my god, I can't even use it correctly.
I...
The hard!
I'm so strong now!
Oh, hello guys.
Don't worry.
My ultimate power!
Oh my god, please stop shooting me.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to grab this.
No, I'm trying to grab the gun.
Let's see.
I saw 1HB.
It's okay.
No, my 1HB.
Oh, God.
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
1HB and a dream.
All right.
It's okay.
We figured it out.
Gotta shoot me over here.
Please.
Please try me.
I'm trying.
I'm trying my best.
Bew, bew, bew, bew, bew, bew, bew.
Lift up the huge things like this?
Alright, we're gonna grab him.
That's right, get out of here!
There you go.
Oh my god, try me.
I don't think I'm collecting your CDs, guys.
I don't think we're collecting the CDs.
Trouble trying to figure out I'm trying so hard to figure
out where anything is right now Oh my god nice wait I can
have use a tree branch hit that stupid wait what oh shit oh
Shit oh Death to all I guess All right, that was an
accident, but I guess I'm angry now
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh
Angry sick we're seeing time Oh Oh Oh my god we have
unlimited power Unlimited power oh Never mind no more
unlimited Power give me a sec There you go Alright got my
gun that's right I free the capture aliens so I can kill
them all right I want to give me that branch there you go
I'm gonna smack them with a tree now I'm gonna poke them
with a tree yeah oh never mind guess we're not using a
branch anymore oh I can shoot 30 of the soldiers.
Wait, what's over there?
How do I get over there?
Oh, yes, I won't get over there.
Alright, let's see.
Wee!
Wait, I can run along the surface of the walls?
Oh, wait!
Oh!
No!
I didn't realize this was supposed last emerald!
I was like, oh hey, chaos emerald.
No!
I got distracted by the shiny thing!
Those idiots, they're destroying everything!
How can I take over this?
I couldn't help it, it was shiny!
I was like, oh hey!
E for emerald.
I have no choice send in the Eggman fleet charge the Eggman
who invited Eggman to this
I couldn't help it the jewel was so shiny the fucking deep
voice going used to triangle button to this planet over
2,000 years ago it's magnificent the perfect killing machine
We're on neutral route.
This sounds very evil.
I mean, you're literally the devil.
So, I don't know.
It feels a little hard to stop the devil.
Alright, guys.
I still have a chance.
I can still be evil, guys.
I just have to, like, not get the sword.
Distracted.
Okay.
Alright, it's touching those green things, right?
Alright.
That's right.
Smashy-smashy.
Oh my god, okay.
I didn't realize that this...
Oh my god, wait, that guy is huge!
Don't give me a sec.
Alright, there you go.
Can't stop.
yourself with from a gun still no matter how big you are are
you ready line up your target in the cannon stock pairs and
fire away okay this guy this one oh nice that's nice of them
how is he still oh wait am i how is it still alive oh i was
supposed to hit the cannon so i wanted to kill the ship yeah
we did it oh that's the good route that's right big boys not
even bulletproof I give you the evil mission I've got
annihilate I've got to get on board the doctors oh oh
annihilate okay that it sounds so like this sounds so like
what's the word it's like I feel like I'm playing Starcraft
okay so annihilating the fleet oh don't worry I still
another gun oh all right so annihilating it all
right nice they don't know which side i'm i can't let him
know which side i'm on i gotta be unpredictable the hypno
ray his voice is so like zerg like the the eyeball in zerg
that's literally what they sound like Like, wait, how do
I...
Ah!
Don't!
Okay, I thought there was a way...
I thought there was a way I would automatically, like...
Yeah, it sounds like an overlaid.
I thought I would automatically follow the ring, you know,
like Sonic.
But I guess this is different rules.
This is...
This is shadow rules.
Alright.
Okay.
protect them i protect them by killing them so they don't
have to go through adulthood that's enough protection all
right so if i do this wait how do i how do i how do i follow
this oh no oh there you go oh it's that button
what can this vehicle do oh my god It has, like, its own
little super jump.
There you go.
Wee!
Super jump!
Oh, hey.
Oh, he has his own gun and everything!
Jesus Christ.
Alright, where are the more fleets?
I gotta make sure I'm doing Eva.
I don't want to accidentally miss out on the Eva.
There's no way Did I miss a fleet?
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
I'm doing more good than evil.
We need more sin points.
We gotta keep sitting.
Use this to fly.
This?
Oh, shit.
Wee.
Oh, I don't have enough sin points.
What do I do?
I'm trying to commit crime.
But instructions unclear.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Well, at least I can...
At least I can slash him.
There you go.
I mean, unless this is good...
My good boy points.
Oh.
shit let's go oh I'm too fast wait wait wait stop oh no oh
no how would I commit evil now oh wait there's another one
okay give me a sec I'm slowly I'm trying to chop it with my
knife but it's not
I was trying to kill him What?
Okay, okay Got you serious, I don't know Oh my god, get me
out of
here Okay, there you go There you go, there you go, we're
fine We're fine, we're fine We're fine Okay Are you serious?
Siri!
I'm at 1 HP!
This is so bad.
This is actually so bad.
Give me your gun.
Damn, not here.
Okay, I can't touch anything.
There we go.
This is so bad.
I literally have 1 HP.
Not here.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta make sure this thing doesn't hit me.
All right, here we go.
No, no, no, no, no, no, don't just, okay, okay, there you
go.
There you go.
I can destroy this.
All right, fuck it.
Oh, fuck it this way.
We'll destroy the cannons first.
I gotta make sure we are still committing evil.
No!
Not here!
All right.
That's okay, I have a gun.
This is very, wait.
Where's my gun?
Wait, what happened to the gun?
There you go.
Alright, you and I.
We're slowly head over it.
There you go.
Oh, God.
Where's my cross here?
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
The bloom.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
We're fine.
if i destroy the ship all right nice we got two ships how is
this not killing him oh no this is bad this is so bad
okay i'm just gonna hope that guy there you go there you go
we're fine we're fine we're fine everything is fine i gotta
be fair oh my god thank god there's rings thank God I found
a ring oh thank God okay back on our little machine okay
okay I'm piece a little too chunky there you go I'm gonna
goomba stop him there you go it works it simply just works
nice goomba stop Finally a ring.
All right.
I have to be so careful.
I don't trust myself.
I don't trust myself controlling this.
All right.
I fly away now.
Wee!
What's up here?
Surely it's another...
All right.
There's a ship right here.
We gotta...
How do we get there?
Oh, the ship is, like, here?
I think?
Yeah, alright.
Oh, hey, Red Ring.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta...
Don't worry, I got you.
We will finally be evil.
Don't worry, we will finally do it, guys.
For evil!
Evil!
Where do you want the scout shadow?
Not here.
So thank you for the secret chat.
Thank you.
Ow!
Oh my god.
Are you fucking...
Okay, okay.
That's fine.
That's, that's fine.
How was I supposed to know I was gonna fucking slip?
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, get this fucking gun out of my hand.
Okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
There you go.
Not here.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it just slips out of my hand like that.
I was trying to destroy this.
All right, I gotta kill the kids.
A little larvae.
all right third ship down finally we're doing evil oh oh oh
okay oh where did he come from okay this gun fuck i'm
running this gun sucks if i knew that gun was gonna suck i
would not have used it oh hey nice yeah all
right nice we got another ship oh my god finally All right.
Here we go.
One more.
One left.
One ship left.
One more vessel.
I hope this is safe.
Oh, it is nice.
Where does the back go?
Good.
Let's go.
So he doesn't know.
Gotta keep him.
Gotta keep him guessing.
He doesn't know if I play.
play both sides.
He doesn't know which side I'm on.
Gotta play both sides.
I think I missed one anyway from the good side.
There you go.
Enemy or ally, he'll never know.
Pew pew pew.
Oh god.
Oh god!
I was expecting!
I didn't expect to run out of ammo!
Let's see, I sub one more.
Nice.
Woo-hoo.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, shit!
I'm running.
Wee!
Four, five, four, five.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know which side I'm on.
Gotta keep him guessing.
wait this has to be a secret right why is there a little gap
there oh sorry fire bad apparently too like what else is bad
are you fucking kidding me oh this guy
hello I am your master where am I trying to run ride to.
Like, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, look, I got a little pet now, guys.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's cool.
I mean, like, oh, wait, I can go.
I didn't realize I can, like, fly faster.
This is actually so hard to control.
All right, here.
All right, nice.
Okay, pressing A makes it go faster.
Oh, there's one more!
One more for even!
For even!
How do I destroy it?
Like, where's the missiles?
Like, where is it?
How am I supposed to be evil?
Are you serious?
I...
Oh.
Oh, the cannon was back there?
Oh, that's...
Okay, we gotta go back.
Let's do this again.
Let's go back for evil.
Alright, let's go.
Here we go.
Ow, is I supposed to die?
It's the cannon!
Alright, here we go.
For evil!
The game said look down.
I thought he met the one in front of me!
No!
I'm not here.
Not here.
Damn, not here.
I jumped off the back.
Okay, I accidentally jumped down.
Okay.
capers still i'm just gonna i'm gonna fast track this it's
fine he's fine he's so healthy
oh my god i don't have no no oh my god it's fine i can it's
fine i'll just run through it i don't need him i don't need
him there you go see i told you guys.
I don't need him.
Where's the cannon?
Wait, you guys lied to me.
There's no cannons here.
Wait, where the fuck is the cat?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh my god, you made me go backwards for...
Oh my god, this was the cannon.
This was the cannon all alive.
You guys didn't even know where the fuck the cannon was.
Spreading information where the fuck is my crosshair
is that where okay i can't literally can't see shit this
crosshair is so fucking tiny
okay that's fine i have to get rid of this anyway oh my god
it's slowly coming towards me yeah evil
This level is so ass.
I love it.
Yay!
E for everyone.
E for evil.
Exactly.
Evil.
Hello, Mr. President.
I was evil.
Sir, your transport is ready.
We must go now.
Sir, please.
Once again, I am have failed my duty to protect oh no sir
it's not over we can continue to fight it's still possible
sir black aliens may have rendered us unable for now but we
will rally sir exactly sir strong and together yes keep the
nation united no matter what happens we'll never surrender
to these creatures never surrender what never what learned
from them sir please hurry okay the
black creatures will feel their own bloody hell does that
say sega on the bot back of the photo oh hey mr president oh
my god that's where all the taxpayer money goes to shadow
follow them make sure they understand their situation You
forgot to bring the photo!
I thought we were family!
He forgot!
Yay!
Eva!
Alright, what is the evil mission?
You need to stop all of the black arms.
Gun has one of the emeralds.
Destroy that human leader's escape bar.
Oh my god, we're gonna you what are we gonna oh no are we
gonna oh no gun gun
guys guys shadow is just being a little edgy today he's not
gonna do anything bad to the president just a little edgy
how do we destroy it Do not interfere with the- Toki's gonna
go on the list.
It's the please please I'm playing a video game FBI.
It's just a video game
What's this those guys are still around this door is coming
in.
Who are those guys these guys?
Oh, these guys I need your gun I interfere to grab your gun
okay all right i gotta make sure i don't interfere with our
soldiers are you serious oh my god i need my one ring okay i
got one ring one ring that ruled them all oh my god where's
my one ring no no no no no oh wait there's an extra gun i'll
grab this
how do i One of our air saucers to proceed along this rail.
All right.
Yay.
How do I stop the president?
Okay, but how do I stop the president, though?
Oh.
Is this the game spent entire level for a single enemy to
finish the map?
Honestly, I don't know.
I don't...
I remember this was a very classic game that the game grunts
did.
Damn, not here.
I'm so sad.
Please, I just need one checkpoint.
All right, it's fine.
Everything is okay.
I'm gonna grab this gun.
Because it has more ammo.
I'm gonna go are you serious are you serious we do have to
line this area of point oh five oh one we are engaging black
aliens on board have any other entry points been compromised
there we go all right we got grab our stuff boo boo boo all
right I think we have everything you got to get where there
are located weapons to shoot the pod?
Where's the pod?
How do I stop the president?
He's doing a wrong thing.
I gotta stop.
I'm here to protect the president.
Don't worry.
Mr. President, I'm here to save you.
I'm here to save you.
I'm going to run away.
your robots well oops give me a sec you think i'm faster
than the president right now get down mr president i'm here
to save you i think oh is he above me now oh shit bro i'm
we're on the same team bro i'm gonna shoot you all right
Okay, we're on the same team, bro.
All right, here we go.
Wait, is he above me?
Wait, is there guns here?
All right, wait, how do I find the president?
No.
I would never...
I'm doing a good thing.
Wait.
Do I just shoot him when he's above me?
Is that what I do?
Oh, I found him and I ignore...
Okay, I'm going back.
I'm going back, Mr. President.
Don't worry.
Oh, I'm...
Oh!
Okay, don't worry.
He has to come through here.
Wait, he's already gone?
Oh, he's ahead of me!
Oh, shit!
I didn't realize he was ahead of me!
I thought he was still behind me!
He's laughing!
He escaped!
There's no way he already escaped.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
What do you mean?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
There he is!
He's in front of me!
What do I do?
Oh god.
There we go, there we go, there we go Oh god No!
No, I got impatient!
I got impatient!
Okay.
Oh my god, no!
No!
No, it's no!
I can't fucking...
I can't do it!
Guys, it's okay, he's still behind me, isn't he?
Is he still behind me?
Don't worry.
The plane is still behind me, right?
We're gonna make it.
Wait, what?
Oh, I forgot to bring the thing.
Okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
He's still behind me, I believe.
I have the gun.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
He's still behind me.
We can still make it
God damn it.
It's so it's still there, right?
Oh my god It's okay.
It's not here It's okay.
We can do this
No!
I wanted to take it.
I wanted to I I can take it.
I can take it.
Look, I got this.
I got all four of this.
Don't worry.
He's still...
We're gonna do it.
We're gonna get the president.
Okay.
I got this.
I can take this.
It's okay.
It's okay to play this stuff behind me, right?
Watch this.
And then...
There you go.
I told you.
Look at that.
We don't need a gun.
What?
Why are they scared?
Why are you scared?
Open the door!
What are you afraid of?
I don't understand!
Oh, these guys.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I figured out what they're afraid of.
all right it's fine it's fine i got a gun it's fine i'm here
oh my god are you fucking kidding me it's okay there's so mr
president's still behind me right it's still behind me right
it's still possible right
all right i'm still getting rid of them you should be safe
now Are you fucking kidding me?
Get out of here.
Wait, where am I now?
That's right!
Evil!
Death to all who oppose me!
Yes!
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow!
Okay
Okay, where's the president?
Where is he?
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where's the president?
Where is he?
He doesn't reset if I die are you fucking kidding me oh my
god
okay okay we're just gonna oh my god oh my god I don't know
what to do oh my god how do I get to the president leave me
alone my one ring what do you what do you mean doesn't
fucking oh my god he's gone he's gone he's like he's gone
He's gone.
Mr. President, please, I'm your biggest...
I think it's too late.
No!
Mr. President, please!
What the fuck is this mission?
Oh my god.
Please, Mr. President, slow down.
i have something very important to tell you mr president
please i have something very funny to tell you mr president
come over here i i don't know what to what do i do in this
scenario
i don't
I can't slide on this curse I don't know what oh my god I oh
my god yes oh
my god almost got him I almost got him grind grind shadow
grind we almost did we can do this oh my god oh my god oh my
god no it's fine it's fine mr president oh crap this i got
something really cool to show you mr i'm trying to touch the
grills bro why can't i touch it okay i i don't have that
perception i just don't have that perception
Fuck this.
I'm not touching.
It's okay.
There's still hope.
Am I...
Am I... Is it hitting?
Is it hitting?
I can't tell.
Did I hit him?
Oh my god, how?
you still here how what are you afraid of oh my god get out
get get out i can't deal with you right now oh i skipped the
same point it doesn't matter it's just meant to be oh wait i
think i can take i don't think i can take it i don't think
it's possible Okay, there you go.
What do you mean?
What do you mean I can't head over there?
How am I?
I can't touch that!
It hurts my feet!
What does it want from me?
Oh, I didn't even notice the hole.
I didn't even see the hole.
Oh my god.
Why won't you let me up?
I'm playing 2D.
Oh, okay.
It's squash.
Alright.
I can't get up.
Help.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
It's okay.
The presence.
There's still hope.
No!
This fucking...
game.
Yes, fucking game.
There's still hope.
The president is waiting for me right now because we're
family.
The president and now we tight like that.
He's still waiting for me.
Are you serious?
Why did I fucking fly there?
I died!
I don't understand.
How did anyone play the non-quality of life version of this?
Did anyone survive?
No!
Damn, not here.
You don't understand.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh, why didn't I take the checkpoint?
It's okay.
Is he still here?
He's not here anymore.
He's not.
No, you don't understand, guys.
The controls for this game?
even on even with like the quality it's absolutely it's
crazy it's the best game of my life no i'm so sad i have to
be good now god why do i have to be good and he's got guys i
don't think I don't think I can kill.
It's so bad.
You know what?
I think it's possible.
I think I can do it.
I know the drill now.
Guys, now I know what to do.
Guys, I know what to do.
I have passion.
I have passion now.
Oh, God.
I'm messing it up again.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Watch this.
Okay.
Not like not right now not right now, but there you go watch
this guys
Watch this guys Yeah And then I'll grab extra bullets from
our gun and then the skit the skit the skit I figured it out
Right here and then we'll just ride this we'll just ride
this we'll bring this along we don't need a car Look at this
look at this I realized this is stronger than a car.
Okay, it's above me.
It's above me.
Watch.
Is this evil, right?
There we go.
There you go.
See, look, look, look.
I'm taking him to the path of evil.
Evil.
There we go.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, there you go.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Wait, which way do I go?
There you go.
See that?
Death to all!
Oh, I was supposed to shoot the play.
Okay, that's awkward.
Oh, that's awkward.
It's okay.
I figured this out.
I don't need to grab shit.
Oh, this is...
It's okay, we don't need that.
We have.
Okay, we don't, we're going to go this way.
Alright, watch this.
So you see, I have that.
And then I have one more.
And then I have another.
Look at that.
I saved it for just this occasion.
There you go.
See, look at that.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
We're all good.
Everything is fine.
And then, and then I do this.
Pop.
Oh shit.
Okay.
It's okay.
I have a lot of coins.
I have a lot of rings.
Pop.
And then I have more rings.
There you go.
And then.
Mr. President.
Okay.
And then I start shooting him, right?
Why is he?
my why about oh there you go it's my cc look at that look at
that look at i'm doing it okay that's not hitting it though
i'm that's what's not how it's not hitting it though there
you go it's fine we're protecting it step to all who oppose
me step to all here you go are you serious
Oh My god, I'm so sad I'm not here
Okay, I can't figure it out.
I figured it out.
I figured it out guys It's very easy once you get the hang
of it.
It's very easy nowhere once you get the hang of it it's very
simple it's very simple you just do this and then you do
that there you go and then and then go over here and then
knock some stuff out and grab a gun Don't worry, don't
worry.
Trust the process.
We're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it, guys.
Just trust the process.
We're gonna make it.
Look, see there's the plate?
There he is.
And then, watch this.
There you go.
See, see, see, look, look.
I told you guys.
Trust the process.
Look, see, see, I'm hitting it.
I'm hitting it, I think.
There you go.
I ran out of bullets.
I didn't think that was possible.
Okay, we need guns.
We need guns.
I've, surprisingly, I have managed to run out of ammo.
much fucking oh my god okay we got oh my surprisingly it has
a lot of fucking ammo okay that's fine we gotta start must
be the president's escape we're just gonna start start
shredding start shredding shadow start shredding it's a play
just gotta keep shredding okay okay this is good all right
it's fine it's fine it's fine we got one more speed run
there you go all right it's fine it's okay it's okay we're
figuring it out see I can be evil okay this okay this guy
got it he's got to die all right it's okay he's waiting for
him the president is waiting for me we can't do this we
can't do it oh my god it's okay it's just a little just a
little bit of ring there you go watch this
All right, there you go.
There you go.
I'm trying to protect the president.
I'm protecting him.
Mr. President.
I have something to show you, Mr. President.
It's something really funny.
I swear.
Mr. President, it's very, very funny.
Oh my God.
I swear.
This is like a lot.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I thought this was the same gun.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god, okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Oh my god, no!
Please tell me.
Oh, are you fucking getting me?
Oh my god, please, Mr. President.
Please, it's so funny, I swear to God.
Oh my god, where is he?
oh my god why is it
so oh my god it's so fast why is it so fast
oh i'm running out i am running out of ammo i am running out
of a lot of ammo are you fucking oh my god forgot about that
I forgot.
Oh, where's the last guy?
It's okay.
I don't have a gun anymore.
So this is a little bad.
We have a shortcut.
It's okay.
I can tank this.
No!
I can't see.
It's over.
It's already over.
I couldn't take it.
I thought I could.
Thought I was strong.
No!
I didn't know!
I want it to be evil, I swear!
Oh, we're so close.
I thought I could be evil.
I'm sorry.
I'm just not that evil.
I hope so I tried.
I tried to be evil if I just didn't have it in me.
Why is being evil?
lot so high why not that evil i was so close it was right
there
i thought i could do it but i was not that evil in the end
i'm just a poser i'm sorry you had to I was just a posy.
Oh my god.
I don't even know where I am anymore.
Embrace the neutrality.
We know you're evil.
It's just you haven't been able to prove it yet.
It's bad.
evil why it's hard why why is it so hard to be evil
it's too late i've lost all hope on being evil
to be fair neutrality is the true edge lord position
Oh my god, we were so close.
My poor gun.
Oh my god, how?
I almost did it.
We were so close.
I should have called for Maria for help.
I'm so sad.
We were so close.
Just...
I found the emerald!
Minecraft is all I need to know, but what kind of bird you
are.
Sonic Man, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you,
Evil?
Yes, patient?
Apparently not.
Yeah, but you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
I have to leave it.
I'm just...
Just neutral.
Oh, hey, I got all the Chaos Emeralds, though.
This makes five Chaos Emeralds.
Five Chaos Emeralds.
Ha, ha, ha.
Shadow, the day of reckoning is near.
Spare the President.
I just wanted to show the President something funny.
I could do a good job.
You saved the President.
I did it, guys.
I saved the President.
I finally know who I am.
shadow we seem to have a problem with rats running loose on
the base return immediately to the black comet and
exterminate them the black comet the black comet no you
don't understand the controls are crazy even with the
quality of life this is so hard to control it's actually i
don't know how people did it.
I actually don't know.
I'm not controlling shadows.
Shadow controls me.
It can't be...
No, I thought so, too.
I was like, can't be that bad.
Oh.
There's no neutral.
We've got to get through to the center of the cover.
Alright, where are the people?
Okay, wait, let's get off this, so...
So I can do that.
Oh, shit.
I was in a sludge.
But that has to be like...
That stuff down there definitely looks toxic.
It's time to kill.
It's cool that Knuckles has seen me do the evil route.
Knuckles like, you're going to be good, right?
I'm like, yeah.
Sure.
Oh, shit.
I gotta grab this.
It's okay.
Yeah, sure, Knuckles.
I'm gonna do a good thing there.
What?
Yeah, Knuckles gonna watch me commit crime.
Alright, nice.
Wait, wait.
3 out of...
3 out of 48?
Where are they all living?
Go, show them some of the red liquid.
I spin the dash out.
No, you don't understand.
Don't understand.
It literally went through him.
I...
Go down.
Why down?
Where's down?
Oh, there's down.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, children.
Yeah.
Use one of our air saucers.
okay i mean i have your thingy why do you use this oh whoops
i don't guess i guess i destroyed it come on scope it in oh
there you go oh my god i got a 548 of you oh nicholas hey
we oh my god there better be more of them on my pathway i
don't know where the fuck these people are isn't a good path
easier for some i don't know idea why why evil is so hard
why is it so hard to be evil i don't understand where are
the bad guys Bro is just man standing emoji.
Oh, these guys?
Here?
What?
We don't go here.
Where do we... Oh, it's here.
Oh my god, this is like a fucking maze.
Wait, these are not people.
These are not the bad guys.
These are just the aliens.
I'm trying to find the bad guys.
Where are they?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm going to swap my saucer.
I have to make sure.
Whoops.
I mean, sure.
Alright, we're going to destroy this because I got to figure
out how to... Oh, there it is.
Oh!
I had to activate it.
Oh.
Okay.
me hello where is the instant teleport oh do I have to jump
okay there you I got my car I was like where is it
instructions unclear where more ammo all right didn't say
get off the saucer just said it teleports me all right we
don't need to get to these guys All right, here we go.
All right, another checkpoint.
All right, nice.
All right, we gotta grab more gun.
More gun.
Wait, there's something over here.
Where's this?
Ow.
Okay, hey, hey, no, no, bad.
What's over here?
What's this?
Alright, let's get rid of this guy.
I don't like him.
He said friend or foe.
I can kill whoever I want.
Ooh, I'll go.
Here?
Oh, there's more people here.
Nice.
Alright, wee!
Now where am I?
I'm so lost.
fucking lot oh my god yeah no that's only four bullets i
need as many as much ammo as i can for oh wait actually
actually oh okay no that's enough ammo hey oh shit hey oh go
back up eight twelve that's a lot that should be enough no
this map is so confusing It is Okay How How I shot through
his legs
Okay Okay Give me your gun 40 I'll take it I was like Why is
it not hitting Why is this not hitting Why I didn't realize
I could shoot through the fucking legs.
Fuck it.
I'm going to use it just for the fun of it.
Just because I can.
Alright, where are the others?
Oh my god, how do I get out of there?
How the fuck?
Oh, it's over here.
God, this level is so fucking confusing.
No, I'll take your...
I'll take your cannon.
That's right.
Who are you shooting, huh?
That's looking right.
Good loss, son.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I'm only at 17 out of 48.
Guys, this is going to be a while.
All right.
Is there more on the other side?
Because that's a TP.
I wish I could see.
I assume I killed them all.
I missed one.
I can't even hit it.
Unless...
Oh!
Where is this area?
Oh my God.
Okay.
Alright.
Buckle up.
Fuck him up.
Fuck him too.
I can't believe it.
I'm back here.
I am only here to suffer.
Why?
Why is being evil so high?
Evil shouldn't be this high!
Okay, I'll grab this ammo.
Alright.
Okay.
We got this, I believe.
There you see, look, I didn't shoot.
I didn't shoot in between his legs this time.
How the fuck do I get on top of this?
Like, is there a jump pad nearby?
to get there?
I have no idea.
I'll kill these guys first.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's cool.
Oh my god, this is so hard to control.
Is it the teleport?
There's a jump pad in the middle?
There is?
Oh my god, this is so fucking hard to control.
all right there's a platform midway there is oh i have one
bullet left i gotta take this platform on my right
where is oh there it is jesus christ this is so hard to see
oh god oh god it's okay there's a missile right here
all right we didn't kill him we did it yeah oh sorry I got a
little angry okay well I should grab the new one actually
all right now I can take my yeah we did it I think that's
all right there's only one guy over there right you see it
up Um, I don't know how to phrase this properly, but I may
or may not be using a GameCube controller.
Just a maybe.
I may or may not be.
I will not confirm or deny what controller I'm using.
Alright, okay, another one down.
I will not confirm or deny what it is.
There we go.
We'll grab 20 bullets.
40.
I'll take the 40 bullets.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Dreamcast controller.
Yeah.
Can I steal this guy's gun?
Nice.
Sorry, that guy was a casualty.
Um, are you gonna help me?
I'm trying my best to be evil right now.
an app still remaining hurry up it's not my fault you made
this fucking crazy ass labyrinth
oh my god
it's already hard enough trying to navigate this shit
i missed one oh my god i missed a lie all right we go back
missing there's no way i spent so much time running around
where could i've missed more look i've killed them all oh
over here i've there we go sorry car crash oh no my thing is
smoking it's not i need to get off this one don't worry
reload death to all who oppose me it's very hard there you
go I accidentally crashed my car too many times, but I got a
new one.
My insurance let me get a new car.
Thank God.
Thank God I have good insurance, guys.
All right, we'll grab this.
Okay.
34.
We're almost there.
Is there anyone from back here?
Okay.
Just slowly backtracking real quick Just to make sure I got
all the evil human beings They're also evil by the way Yeah,
I think I got all of them Yeah, my insurance covers alien
hovercrafts Thank God I have really good I have really good
auto insurance
Alright, down I go Oh my god
Do I need to, though?
I'm tired at it.
It didn't stop.
Like, what's the...
Okay, okay.
There's no point.
There's no point in that.
I'm like, what's the point of stopping it?
There was none.
There was zero point.
There's zero reasoning for me to stop that.
I should be like...
Oh, I should be...
Okay.
Okay, nice
Another one down
Okay, yeah, how dare they start Stop resisting For the
greater good Stop resisting
Yeah Nice Huh?
Good?
Yeah, I'm going I'm a good person Are you fucking kidding
me?
Okay I'm a good person They're evil human beings All the
aliens want to do What they had They shot the human shot
first guys
You're just trying to give us the cure for cancer Then we
shot him So I'm helping them I'm a good person Not a good
person probably I'm not a good person probably Don't worry!
Don't worry, citizens!
I shall save us!
Oh my god, four more.
Just four more to go.
Oh my god, where are they hiding?
Where are you hiding?
We're gonna find you!
Where are the last humans?
Where are they?
Where are the last humans hiding?
where are you try to find the last humans left on this
planet where do I go I gotta swap cars like I have to start
this apparently where how do I how do I start I come in
peace, guys.
Oh, no.
I keep crashing my car accidentally.
No, stop.
Stop.
I just want to go up.
Where do I go?
I keep crashing, crashing my car.
Oh, no.
My car's not doing so well.
Guys, I don't know where to go.
Oh, I have to kill him.
Okay, that's where I had to go.
Did I do it?
Yeah!
Start!
What?
Who shot me?
Oh my god, please.
I...
Oh, it's over here.
It's okay.
Got you now!
That's fucking right, you can't disappear from me.
Alright, here we go.
Three!
Oh, shit.
One!
Yay!
We did it!
Let the humans await their final judgment day.
That's right.
E for evil.
Well done, Shadow.
We did it.
E for evil.
Oh, hey, Sonic.
Where were you?
We did it.
We saved humanity.
I can't let you go.
Not like this.
You, you're the one who destroyed the Ark and killed
everyone.
It's time to settle this once and for all.
I destroyed the Ark?
What happened?
But they were evil.
I was born to bring order to the humans.
These humans, they don't value life.
They're going to pay.
I did it, I saved the Latinas!
What they've done.
Shadow now kills Sonic.
Sonic, if you try to stop me, I'll destroy you too.
But didn't I save them?
I've waited years.
Oh shit!
Okay, also who's the other guy?
I guess I have no choice.
um how kill how kill um do i kill sonic gotcha sonic that's
right i don't know how kill where's my gun gun where's my
gun where's my gun
he's in the other yeah i was gonna say who would What the
fuck is this guy?
Oh, what the fuck?
Aim for the head?
How do I just...
Get out of here, Sonic.
This isn't your fight.
What the...
Oh, shit!
He hit back!
And he's in the air?
You can approach the weapon?
Oh, there's his.
There's a gun.
get out of here get out of here okay there you go chat wait
okay but like how how kill like guys what the i am so
confused oh i have to use him as a trampoline now it's time
to Oh I see I see I see Sonic get over here.
I need to use you Sonic Sonic get over here Sonic Sonic
Sonic Sonic Sonic Sonic There you go there you go
Oh my god, I'm so mad What I shot you
Sonic, Sonic, I need you.
This is like, this is so confusing.
Sonic, please cooperate.
Sonic, get over here.
There you go.
Are you serious?
Are you?
Okay, I got it, though.
I got it, I got it.
There you go.
Yeah!
Oh, now's playtime's over.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, fuck off, Sonic.
This is the most confusing fight I've ever done.
Sonic, get over here!
Sonic!
Sonic, Sonic, get your ass over here!
Sonic, I need you!
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, what is he doing?
Bro is gapping.
Sonic, your friend's not going to your big friend's not
going to help you forever.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Are you kidding me?
I pulled.
Oh, that's right.
Explose!
Chaos!
This works.
This works too.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
I just gotta keep doing evil.
Sonic, please.
Sonic, please!
I know, you and I just hanging out with you and your big
brother.
Your big brother can't save you forever.
Come on.
Get over here.
Sonic?
Sonic, please.
Sonic, come on.
Please, you gotta work with me here, bro.
You gotta...
You gotta fucking work with me, bro.
Like, honest, bro, I'm so mad.
Sonic doesn't even care.
Sonic, please.
There we go.
Sonic, you're like my little jump bat.
This is so dumb.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe this game didn't get a sequel, guys.
I wonder why I I wonder why this game never got a sequel I
why didn't we why wasn't this game ever remastered who would
have thought we'll never know the world's greatest mysteries
truly a mystery in the Sonic fandom
Jesus Christ.
This is so dumb.
Hold still, you double.
Get out of here.
Fuck you, Sonic!
Hey, I love this game when I was a child.
Hold still, you double.
Oh my god, not again.
Bro, he's literally one.
Sonic, please.
hold still you devil are you fucking oh sorry is the goddamn
hand hit me oh my god it's stupid you're up fuck you fuck
you I'm just gonna kick your ass give me the explosion power
I'm so close to get to be able to explode I just got beat up
Sonic one more time.
Okay, I just gotta hit him one more time to do it.
Hold still, you double.
It's so close.
I'm just gonna go explode.
Are you serious?
Sonic!
I thought we had it.
There we go.
It's time to end this.
I just gotta beat up Sonic a couple of times.
Yay!
We came over.
We did it.
Evil!
Congratulations, Toki, you killed Sonic.
Yay!
Oh no!
That's right!
Should have stood in my path, Sonic!
Finally, I've got all the Chaos Emeralds.
We did it!
how could you shadow thought we were best friends forever
why is he like giving me flirt bedroom eyes i'm shadow the
hedgehog the ultimate life form born to protect and serve
the dark lord black doom satan of these chaos emeralds this
world will become I am we did it we saved the world what the
fuck was that wait that's how it is bro what the fuck was
the laughing animation we did it guys we saved the world yay
what an ending I mean if he's happy it's technically a good
ending
Bro, what happened?
Also, who the fuck was Maria then?
Clearly Maria was not that important.
I need three endings?
Okay, what?
The three is neutral and good, right?
Oh, it's...
a different story path to see the ending okay we can get two
of the other endings and then that will unlock the true
ending right yeah but reloaded we could just do three to get
the true ending which is a lot better than 10.
i don't know three is a lot less now for the other six
endings
yeah i feel like i'm missing like 50 actually not even 50 i
feel like i missed 80 of the story i i was like doing evil
task and then i fought sonic and this other guy who i don't
even know
like his big brother.
I was like, what happened to the president?
Like, what happened?
I'm so confused.
And I'm like, what happened to Igman?
He just left.
But no, no, no, no.
No,
no.
But no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
A lot of it happened in Sonic Adventure 2 or just wasn't
explained.
Black Doom is Shadow's genetic dad and wants his son to help
him destroy Earth because he's evil.
Wait, my dad's a human?
He fucked a hedgehog?
Patch arrested.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Or is he a hedgehog?
Like, wait, is Black Doom a hedgehog or a human?
Yeah?
Oh.
Okay.
Black Doom is not human.
Wait, my dad's an alien?
I assume a scientist created me.
Bam.
Yeah, I was creating a tube.
All right.
Can I select diabolical power?
Oh my god.
Do you... Is it telling me to do all the levels again?
No, I'm...
Don't do this to me.
Don't... Oh my god.
Don't... You mean I don't Have a level select?
You mean I can't just select a level?
I...
Don't do this to me.
Don't, don't, don't do this to me.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, that's just...
There you go.
I just kept accidentally pressing the cutscene over and over
again How do I skip this?
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, no Okay, we got to be neutral Oh, no.
Oh, no, okay
Okay, okay, okay I mean we know how to be neutral at least
it has no select it's okay it's okay we can be faster yeah
yeah yeah it's okay guys i just gotta get a gun we gotta
kill him and grab a gun and then it'll be easy there you go
watch this okay there you go one chaos emerald
my guns that's fine that's fine oh shit what that hits me we
gotta get the car
it's okay we can skip all of this we don't need rings we
just gotta go fast as long as we don't get out of bounds we
just need to grab the rings oh my god oh my god guys i'm
losing my I'm losing my hope very slowly.
I'm very slow.
I'm losing my hope.
Okay, I'll grab.
I'll take that gun.
Oh my god.
Just leave me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Where the fuck is...
my car where is the car the car made everything so easy
there you go gotta go fast oh we gotta check what oh my god
okay as long as i do a good one good thing it should be fine
i should Get the good ending.
There's the car.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
There's good in the world.
Well, there's that's the problem you had hoped to begin
with.
Oh, God.
We got to make sure we don't fucking go out of bounds.
Are you fucking?
Are you?
Oh, my God.
Please.
Blinda.
Damn, not here.
Is there, like, can I drive backwards?
Guys, I know you guys are like, oh my god.
Oh my.
I was just saying, I was like, there's no way you cannot
drive back.
All right.
It's fine, it's fine.
I learned how to drive backwards.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Everything is fine now.
We have a car.
everything should be fine okay nice it's here it's the chaos
emerald I found it yeah thank you thank you thank you igman
isn't there because he had beef with shout out the beef what
they had cost of what shout out did to his wife thank you
for super chat thank you a for amazing all right neutral we
just gotta go straight straight down the neutral path
doesn't this know it's wonderful I'm having a great time
it's so fun it's so fun oh my god I have two there's five
guys I don't know if I'm strong enough I don't know guys I
don't know if I'm strong enough guys There's five more Oh my
god Oh my god I can't believe in the original They made you
try and kill all of them That's so fucked up That That's
actually so fucked up Apparently you're not allowed to leave
any of them alive but like with the mod you can like miss a
couple of them like be strong okay we're fine there you go
think of it that's crazy how the kids how are kids able to
our kids able to fucking kill all of them for all any of
these routes how are the kids able to not do the neutral
route i actually did it are you okay are you okay i need to
know as one of the children that actually tried to get all
endings are you okay
me we had the time it's crazy how it's crazy i didn't make
more of this no you don't understand i don't care if i'm
hitting everything i'm trying to i'm trying to be neutral
right now guys i don't know the biggest issue guys is i
don't know if i'm strong enough for the to redo it for the
good ending I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm already...
I'm already losing my hope.
My hopefulness.
The fire in my eyes are gone.
The shadow think of the content.
Do it for the Latina Stokey.
Oh no, not here.
all right gotta be neutral remember to be neutral okay
we're five i have to be neutral satan i'm sorry gotta be
neutral
oh my god i just remembered the charming b level two guys
guys i don't Guys, guys, there's so much more left.
I don't want to touch it, though.
I don't want to.
Touch the drawer.
I don't want to touch it.
It's bad.
It's a bad drawer.
Woo!
You must touch it.
Ignoring your father is a neutral way to do it.
Touch the jewel.
Alright, there we go.
Yay!
We did it!
I don't take orders from anyone.
I do as I decide.
That's right.
I don't take orders from anyone.
That's why I don't have the jewel's consent.
No, I don't...
What if the jewel didn't want me to touch it?
I didn't know that.
Excellent neutral victory.
It's like that Futurama video where you're like, well, how
do you feel?
I don't feel neither...
Like, what do you say?
The Futurama neutral people?
I feel neither joy or sadness for this decision.
Tell my wife.
I wonder if there are any chaos emeralds around here.
I know this place.
Gotta get grand.
Oh yeah.
If I do more good.
I'll skip the stuff for me.
Oh please.
Please.
I gotta do the good stuff.
Ah fuck.
Charmy, please!
Okay.
Oh my god, there is no way I was gonna get all this get
this.
Hey, listen!
Charmy, please.
Charmy, I need to go fucking get another crystal.
I gotta be neutral again, Charmy.
Whee!
That's crazy that there's no hero select.
That's actually the crazy thing.
is like not here there's no level select for the endings as
i'm i'm actually so amazed by that that that was the concept
that they decided not to add
but that's the best part toky yeah yeah yeah yeah what do i
Oh, I fucking
All right, I guess I gotta beat them up.
All right, open it up got my car Don't you just want to
replay this over and over and over?
I don't yeah, yeah, yeah
Guys, oh my god, I love it.
I love this This game's so much.
Yay!
The ride!
No!
Damn, not here.
Where did it take me?
Okay, it's not that far.
Back down, I go.
The thing is, I followed the path, but it went so fast that
I fucking it's like, you know, it's like my fear on water
slides Like you're going so fast that you slip off the
slide.
That's literally my greatest fear I never do water slides
because of that if it's not I don't understand people who
can do water slides where it's not fully enclosed That's the
point That's the thrill of it, Toki I
All right, here we go.
Yes, we got a checkpoint.
It's okay.
Wee!
Neutra!
It was...
My sister and I almost slipped off.
It was pretty fun.
But that was so terrifying.
All right, here we go.
Yay!
Neutra!
No, this is a new cutscene, because I also did neutral on
this, too.
We did neutral on this one.
See, because we were like, why the fuck is Dr. Eggman here?
Guys, I did it.
I found the fourth Chaos Emerald.
All right, here.
This part.
This part is where I have to do neutral this time.
All right.
This is where I got to, this is where I got to, like, not
shoot Dr. Eggman's thing.
all right we got good i've got to go to igman's temple
all right all right man i'm coming over all right this is
where we're gonna get new content you just run past that
okay but first i need a i need to grab your shit though
thanks for your shit all right goodbye oh my god what the
fuck okay get this guy out of here, though.
But I'll get him out of here.
Okay, I'm trying to help you, bro.
I'm just slapping with my fucking tree branch.
There we go.
It's fine.
I got a tree branch.
Wait, I actually want...
Fuck this sword.
Give me a gun.
Alright, we leave.
Alright, here we go.
Wee!
I got his ass.
I whacked him with a branch.
Alright.
Alright, we leave.
Goodbye.
We gotta be neutral.
Oh, what?
Oh shit, I have to kill them.
Alright, I guess I can't be neutral.
Okay.
I'm feeling so evil right now.
I gotta get this gun.
This gun seems better.
all right is that it there you go get the kids out of here
the gas is making me think evil thoughts guys I can get into
this gun vehicle is why isn't my dad talking to me now dad
where are you dad where my dad stopped talking to me I don't
understand dad guys why isn't my dad talking talking to me
just because I just because I don't feel evil and are good
that's messed up dad my dad went to get milk you think he'll
come back but you're a disappointment you chose neutral so
the voices are gone now dad no I said I'm I'm sorry!
I'll be evil next time!
I swear!
I swear I can be evil!
Just not today!
Just taking a little break!
What the fuck?
Oh shit, wait, this is a god of war gun!
Yeah!
Our last one.
Holy shit.
It's that little great gun from God of War.
Alright, that's all of them.
Alright, nice.
Oh, sorry, Gears of War.
Sorry, there's so many wars.
No!
Not here.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
This is like, give me your bazooka.
Give me the bazooka.
Alright.
This guy out of here.
Get him out of here.
Alright.
There you go.
That's right.
Get your ass out of here.
Alright, I got this.
Okay, this time.
Everything is fine this time.
Have you tried...
In a Sonic game?
How dare you tell me to slow down in a Sonic game?
Kratos with a gun.
That's in the third God of War of Game.
Alright.
We're here now.
Oh, oh.
How about I leave?
Alright, here I go.
Skip the another one.
And get in that.
Get in the robot shadow.
You might be at the support of him to your dad, but I'm
still here.
We'll still commit crime together.
There we go.
Huma stomp.
Since that he can also get Huma stomp too.
oh my god we're almost there we just have to go here and
then that's like the fast lane fast track okay okay um we
almost got okay guys okay i'm just gonna there
technically it worked Yeah, yeah.
It still works.
It technically still works, guys.
If you think about it, technically it's still work.
Alright.
Yeah, but they're all useless to this.
Alright, we're gonna go here and then fast track.
And then...
That's right!
Chaos Control!
We're here.
Ow.
We're still here.
Don't worry.
Get on.
We're going travel.
No, I didn't skip the stupid bird.
We're still here.
We're still here on the bird.
It's okay.
Despise.
We're so neutral.
tell Sonic I said hello it almost skipped the stupid bird
part oh my god there's the ship I'm right there I finally
made it neutral neutral you're not getting away from me this
time that's right dr. Eggman
That's right.
I'm ready.
This has to be a new level, right?
Right, guys?
Right?
This should be a new stage, right?
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my God.
Thank God it's new.
See, as in cool.
What?
What the?
That's me.
how can this be how can there be two of me oh my god this is
gonna be weird that's weird big man but those black
creatures are a formidable adversary I must return to the
base to devise a new plan I'm you but I love latinas even
more than you.
Hit the Latina Lover Club.
Oh, no!
He's questioning his existence now!
What the fuck?
Oh!
Oh, it's him!
Okay, what is the neutral option here?
Find the entrance.
Okay.
All right, we gotta...
We're gonna get to the base and be neutral.
Damn, not here.
The one gap.
The one fucking gap that happened to not jump through.
Oh my god, just because I wanted to kill him.
All right, I gotta grab a gun.
I gotta grab a gun.
give me your gun I gotta get him away oh my god don't you
fuck with me okay there you go what's this all right it's
time to shred grinding I'm gonna grind on it it's the
doctor's ocean all right we don't mess with them we don't
mess with them shadow we gotta be neutral we have no opinion
whatsoever oh yeah is okay all right oh what the he punched
me wait that's not fair just to think he gets like he gets
misses why don't i get misses we're nearly both shadow hello
oh my god It's not fair.
I should also be equipped with misses.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
We don't need him.
Give me that laser gun.
I gotta have a gun.
Oh, nice.
We need this.
Alright, jump.
Jump.
Alright.
I'm not doing your mission.
it, but I just need to head over here.
Oh, please tell me I'm going the right way.
Oh, I hope I'm going the right way.
I can't tell.
Am I shooting him?
I'm not.
Hey, hey, don't shoot me.
Maybe I can use my
heart.
Behold the ultimate power.
I almost saved it.
I almost saved it because I was gonna like, oh my god.
I'm getting out of here.
I'm not going through that.
Yeah.
It's fine.
I could have saved it too.
I know if I got off the robot in front.
I know.
If I got off the robot, And press Y I could I Oh my god Oh
my god Okay is it moving I can't tell Oh my god If only the
camera can move If only the camera can move If only
I can't move the camera I can't Nice save things Things I
know I know
I can't guys I know you're like just move the camera
Apparently I can't I cannot move the camera It was a good
save Wait I could have are you telling me I could oh my god
There's no way
I didn't mean map the second stick I forgot to map guys did
you know that you can map the second stick did you guys know
that oh my god you can move oh my god there is another stick
there was another stick
Dash opportunity present.
Oh my god, guys.
There was another.
There was another stick.
Guys, there was another stick, guys.
It's fine.
Look at that, guys.
Look at that.
I forgot to find the other stick.
Look.
Okay, I have a good explanation for this.
Guys, guys, guys.
I have to re-bind this all myself.
Okay, I have to re-bind it all myself.
Guys, I have a really good explanation for this.
I have to re-bind all of this myself.
And I didn't realize I missed a binding.
Oh my, this is hell.
Oh my god, he's just standing there.
Oh my god.
Oh, please.
Oh, thank God.
I have another gun.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
That's not fair.
You know it.
You know that's not fair, bro.
This is fine.
Oh, my God.
I hate all of them.
Oh, oh, fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
Okay, but sometimes the camera is locked.
All right, there you go.
Yay.
That.
It's all these.
It's all of these.
Alright.
Shredding it.
I'm shredding it.
Alright, here we go.
I hate.
Oh my god, I hate the shadow bots.
I hate it because all I have are fucking bazookas.
The bazookas are so hard to aim!
That's it.
I'm using the ultimate power.
Get me out of here!
Keep going!
There we go.
Alright, we did it.
There we go, we did it.
I truly am the ultimate lifeblood.
Yay!
E for everyone!
E for E good.
My ultimate power.
We're not evil right now.
E neutral.
Sorry.
Ne-neutral.
And neutral.
Don't forget to map this to your bank account.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, E for equilibrium, guys.
What the fuck?
You two are going to stop me.
Move aside I'm not stopping anyone.
I'm just neutral Please I need to know who am I the ones
that look like me He has an existential crisis?
Wow, what you and Omega are my creation dad, but you betray
me as you stand here before me.
So now I will destroy you both turning you into scrap metal.
What?
I will defeat you once and for all.
This is what you get for turning against your master.
Target.
But then!
I thought we cool like that, though.
We not cool like that?
Oh my god, please.
Omega, do something.
Omega, please.
Please do something.
I forgot to grab a ring.
ring.
Oh yeah, I have two dads.
Please, please Omega.
Please, I just need you to help me somehow.
I'm trying!
Oh, there it is.
Alright, we eliminated him.
Alright, it's fine, it's fine.
We got him, we got him.
on enemies oh my god there you go oh shit nice oh shit Omega
do something do something oh shit behold the ultimate That
farm!
Done.
With the power of Fun and Mash!
Let's go.
Easy.
E for easy.
That was pretty ultimate.
I don't believe you.
That's kind of cheating.
What happened?
What is it called?
BPM?
Beats for...
Beeps per minute.
I knew it.
I knew you were lying.
See for cheating.
Beeps per second.
What does APM even say?
Whoa, what's this?
See for could be your dad.
This ultimate life form they keep referring to is the black
hedgehog.
And he died.
Oh.
I must be the android Dr. Eggman created.
Then it's clear what needs to be done.
You're going straight to the place you created me from.
What?
Where am I?
Where are we going?
Shadow is dead?
I'm rev- wait, I'm not the original Shadow?
I am so fucking confused.
It's okay, I'm shredding it though.
I look so cool.
I might be confused, but I oh shit I didn't realize I didn't
realize like I thought this was just this
Alright, what is the what does he want?
Activate the volcanic defense system Head to the center.
Okay head to the center that's wait, but there's no neutral.
Wait, how do I be neutral then?
Terrain indicates triangle jump is the most suitable way to
proceed.
Triangle jump.
Wee.
Okay.
Oh, both are neutral.
I was confused because I was like, how neutral is If both
were good, bad.
Wait, what's the non-neut?
All right, do we help Omega?
Do we help?
Wait, they're both neutral?
So it doesn't matter?
Wait, why is like Dr. Igman helping me?
Help Omega?
Okay.
We'll help Omega.
We gotta find the center.
Wherever that is.
Now, I'm helping Omega.
Omega's a homie.
That's right.
I think I'm helping him.
At least the music is sick as hell.
I don't know where I'm going, but I think I'm going the
right way.
Why?
Where am I?
Oh, where?
I don't know where I'm going.
I don't know.
There's so many things in this level.
No!
I refuse!
I must head to the center.
You can't stop me.
You're not my real dad.
My real dad's Satan.
Shadow Android's shattered armament includes some very
relentless lock-on missiles.
Alright.
There you go.
Now!
Dad.
Shadow, how come Sega lets you have two dads?
Briding it?
Alright, nice.
I'm treading.
I'm shredding.
I'm looking sick as hell right now.
Oh, Tony Hawk is quiet now.
Let me go.
Whoops.
Okay, maybe don't fucking put bombs there.
So cool.
You're still ahead of your time.
Let me go.
I'm so fucking fast.
Wham!
Oh my god, gotta go fast.
Gotta go fast!
Gotta go so fast!
Damn, not here.
Oh, I got it.
It went too fast.
No, it works.
It works.
At the last, I'll hear the truth from you.
Guys, apparently there's a thing called too fast.
They took pity on you.
Yeah, I think the reason I put a checkpoint there that
people might have went too fast too many times
All right Nice to see you shadow android and you too omega
it certainly looks as if you've well done quite a bit of
damage down there But did you really think that you could
challenge me?
Damn, right I will destroy you and reign supreme Yes,
doctor.
You will regret ever having created me.
You're going straight to hell.
Whoa!
Can't say that.
Shadow!
Hell exists in the Sonic universe?
I'll turn both of you into Scrap with my greatest and
greatest invention.
Yeah, Shadow wants to commit murder!
real blood it's time for missiles fever what oh no oh no
okay wait wait i got it oh my god come on let me hit that
are you fucking oh my god are you fucking kidding me are you
fucking kidding me what hit me the last one oh there it is
yeah Ring time
What in other words, by stopping the third reel yourself you
can deal an attack against Edmund.
Oh no, I hit myself
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, you heard yourself you hear yourself
I hate I hate this I hate this I hate this
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I got a weapon.
It's over I got a weapon now a man what you gonna do now?
Oh my god.
Oh, this is hell There you go There you go.
We got it.
God this this boss fight this this boss fight let me just
say this boss fight is very inferior it it sure is a boss
fight it really is a boss fight oh my god okay there you go
are you fucking oh my god where am I where Okay, there you
go.
I, okay, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, I got one.
Get this out of my hand.
The least annoying punch.
Is this hurt him?
Okay.
That's fine, that's fine.
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
It really is.
Not boss, fight of the century.
Oh my god, let me...
Are you...
It's okay.
What did he do?
What happened?
Let's go.
Does it hurt me?
Wait, what's shadow fever?
Oh, that's right!
That's right!
Get over here!
Get over here, get over here, get over here, get over here.
Oh, I got shot.
No!
I'm not here.
I'll turn both of you into scrap with the greatest and
greatest invention.
Final targets confirmed.
Commencing combat.
No!
No, he can't do this to me.
My green.
Oh, my greed!
Oh, no!
Why am I so greedy?
Why?
In other words, by stopping the third real user, you can
deal with it.
I hate him.
I hate him so much.
Damn.
Not here.
I'll turn both of you into scratch.
Oh my god.
I have to watch this intro.
I have to watch this intro every time.
Why is it one hit, one kill?
Why?
okay that's fine I thought I thought I don't know for some
reason in my head I thought I'd be okay I just I don't know
why I don't know why I thought I'd be okay there I hate him
I hate him so much
You can deal an attack against Eggman.
Come on.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Sonic legs touch me!
Oh my god.
We almost got Shadowfest.
You need a short kind of weapon to strike an Eggman's
cockpit.
There you go.
My beautiful range!
Oh!
The stupid fucking lava!
Yes!
Shadow Fever!
Get over!
Oh my god, that's... There you go.
Oh my god, one more.
Come on, get over.
Get over here.
Shadow Fever!
It's Shadow Fever!
Oh my god, you fucker!
You fucker!
it's fine it's fine
are you fucking kidding me
he is the egg man he's got the master plan I tried to take
you but this is the end for you so we did it neutrally we
did it e for e neutral we're equal
that's right look what I got.
Got you, Jim.
Got your chaos.
He for Igman.
Finally, I've got all the chaos emeralds.
I made you.
And this is how you repay me.
I mean, you try to kill me first.
Shadow Ash.
The ultimate battle life form.
What the fuck is this game?
But I will now leave this empire and androids will rule this
is who I am
It's surprising this isn't one game of the year.
He's so cool goodbye doctor Wait, I killed Why
Oh my god, did I just kill dr Because if only this was the
true ending guys rip fatality honestly this should have
imagine if like this in this game we just kill off Eggman
and he just never shows up again yeah he killed yeah he
killed his dad that's next maximum edgy this bro Eggman's
fucking dead he just killed Jim Carrey you skip the song
wait would have been a new song or is it the same song.
Oh, what the?
I thought!
Oh, I thought it was the same song, so I skipped it.
Are you serious?
Each ending has a new... Okay, well, just... It's okay.
It's okay.
I got an idea, guys.
I got an idea.
Don't worry.
It's like I never skipped it.
I didn't know!
I thought each song was the same.
Oh, I could... Wait, I can listen to it in the settings?
Okay, wait, let me check.
Also, also, guys, tickets are out now.
Tickets for Made Cafe out now.
For those who want to still grab the live tickets.
Wait, can I still listen to it?
Wait, let me try.
Let me see.
I must be able to listen to it, right?
In the...
I...
Wait, uh...
Wait, am I re-watching this?
Oh, wait, that's not what I want it.
Is it in the library?
Wait, is it?
Wait, no?
I think this just shows all the cutscenes for that area.
Right?
Yeah, it does.
It shows...
Oh, my God.
Take me out of here.
Alright, let's see if I can listen to it in.
Oh, my God.
There's select...
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
Which one is it?
Guys, which one is it?
Or the song name?
There's event, is it event three?
Waking up?
Oh, is this?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh.
That's the one thing we can always count on for Sonic games.
The songs are just fucking sick as hell.
That's one thing they get right every time.
You know what other Sonic game I've been wanting to play for
the longest time?
It's a Sonic Boom But I researched it And it's almost
impossible to get to play It's almost impossible to make it
work on modern PCs
It's the one game I've wanted to play for the longest time
Yeah, it's the most broken Sonic game
it's that yeah apparently like there's no way to like mod it
in a way where you can actually make it run on pc like
modders gave up they were like we can't do it alien like i'm
sorry we can't do it
i don't know
Cannon Castle Runner?
Yeah, the Wii.
It was originally made.
Wasn't it originally made for the Wii?
But even then, like, modders have made it work on, like,
other...
Was it originally on the Wii U?
Yeah.
The modders have made Wii U games work on PC, but everyone
gave up on Sonic Boom.
Not even the most dedicated Sonic fan can make it work.
is saying a lot because Sonic has a lot of dedicated fans.
Literally a fan, literally a fan made the reloaded, like
literally made this much so that Sonic, the Shadow the
Hedgehog would be a playable game on PC.
Yay.
All right, let's go, or it's good, it's time to be good now.
wait can i actually select oh my god it's possible wait but
like do i is it i play one round wait for select mode do i
just play the one map or do i get to or like um or like does
it make me like do uh oh i just to replay the level okay
Okay, it's just one map.
Okay, here we go again.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
It's okay, guys.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
Here we go again.
All right, we aim for good.
Right off the bat.
Here we go again.
We gotta finish the story.
All right.
All right, we gotta kill 40.
Oh, shit.
we go again.
We got this, and then we can unlock the true ending
afterwards.
Don't worry, Sonic.
I'm here for good now.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm here for good, but I need your gun.
Give me a sec.
I swear to God, it's for very good reasons.
He'll understand.
He's dying for his country.
Okay, like if I'm a good person, you shouldn't be hurting me
All right, we gotta go slow because I gotta know which ones
I gotta know that I'm killing the right people All right,
there you go All right Got more
Fine.
Bupu.
Oh, shit.
You're not dead yet.
Bupu.
All right.
14.
Wait, I missed two?
Oh, my God.
That's it.
I'm taking you down with me.
All right, here.
All right, we got to go back.
We got to find them all.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
They're so fucking tiny.
Okay, I need your gun.
It's fine.
I'm just killing one extra.
All right.
you what do you mean stop station need to stop touching me
that's on them okay i need new ammo
all right where's the all right halfway there all right nice
we got another gun what the fuck okay that is illegal okay
we can't skip anything That's the worst part.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I thought he was an alien.
Okay, that's on him.
Why was he there?
That was on him.
That was his fault.
Alright, nice.
There we go.
Okay.
There's another alien here.
We gotta kill the alien.
okay nice got another gun oh my god we're almost there we're
so close
hello alien 10 more 10 more oh sorry miss input he was in
front of my gun are you fucking sorry Sorry.
You guys saw it, right?
You guys saw him.
He was in front of my gun.
That was on him.
Maybe if he wasn't in front of me, he wouldn't have got
shot.
Just stop resisting.
Alright, nice.
Tell me where it is.
We need seven more.
Okay, nice.
Wait, where's the...
Don't they have guns?
who?
Where are their guns?
Okay, I need your gun.
Nice.
Don't worry, I'll tell your wife that you died honorably to
a hedgehog.
Surely that she'll be very impressed.
Okay.
Whoops.
One more.
We did it!
Yeah!
It's okay.
We don't have to kill all...
We can miss one or two.
Disgusting black creatures.
And we get an emerald out of it too?
Oh my god, an emerald came out of his butt.
Yay!
A for awesome.
We did it!
At least we get a new level right off the bat.
Thank fucking God.
Don't worry, God.
Shadow has his body cam up.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat thingy thingy.
shadow he can't just say that major cities around the world
and every city is reporting significant damage and
casualties among them Westopolis has received the heaviest
casualties due to its weakened defense system wait is this
like new or old cutscene unconfirmed sources have also
reported seeing a black hedgehog in Westopolis shadow deploy
the troops now and if you find shadow with the black aliens
then kill them all what isn't shadow on our side gave you an
order soldier he's evil and he's the enemy why doesn't he
trust me I killed all the aliens me shadow this time you're
mine whoa just cuz I'm a black headjoy now that was sweet
shadow yeah well I'm not here to save you thought you
something like that how about a little friendly competition
don't waste my time bro that general is pretty up we found
the third chaos emerald in this city our mission here is
done i think sonic likes me yes that means welcome to the
next level yeah he's making it really hard for me to stay on
the good side get back here all right nice okay new level
thank God.
Yeah, how come they don't attack Sonic?
How come the fucking soldiers attack me and not Sonic?
All right, what's the good side?
Stop.
Is he?
Stop the alien.
How do I stop it?
Wait, but how do I stop it?
Oh no.
Please don't tell.
No.
Oh no.
Oh.
If you do enough damage to me I should be able to get
through.
Oh yes.
Oh no.
You're so fucking
Yeah, what did I?
What did I do?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
I need a gun.
Oh, thanks.
Thanks, Sonic.
Thanks.
Thanks for helping out
Oh, I'm so sad I'm so sad.
I'm so I'm so sad Please no no No
How do I get out of here?
Okay.
It's okay.
We can still make it.
We can... It's okay.
It's doable.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's still doable.
self where is he where is he where the fuck is he
oh my god where's the alien ship please
what is this what the fuck is this it's okay it's okay it's
like oh my god this is guys he thinks he gets guys, guys, I
have the... I don't have a gun.
I...
I have... I have the sock.
Okay, okay, it's fine.
I got this.
It's okay.
It's still possible.
We can still make it.
It's okay.
I didn't realize I had the wrong Weapons, but we can still
we can still make it we can still
Oh my god, please for the love of God
Okay, this is still possible guys This is so winnable It's
so winnable It's so winnable There I see him I see him I see
him I don't have ammo anymore.
I don't have ammo.
It's okay.
We'll find another.
This is where I'll get my gun.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, please.
Why?
Okay,
okay, we got it.
I just gotta go find one guy with the gun.
Okay, okay.
Where's your gun?
All right, it's fine.
And now we kill him.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
it's okay
what the fuck okay it's okay it's okay we got a gun we got a
gun we got a gun we got a gun we got a gun we got a gun we
got a gun we just gotta get their guns we just gotta get
their guns
yeah i'm making good progress we got a gun What the fuck?
What?
That?
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
This is the opposite of gotta go fast.
Okay.
Oh my god, there he is.
There he is.
Yeah, we did it.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, why was this easier?
Why was this easier?
I won't allow them to do what they want to anymore.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God we did it.
We got him.
This is easier than the present.
Who is that?
Oh, I'm so, I'm so happy.
I'm so So happy.
I love evil dad.
B for beautiful.
B for bueno.
Look, I don't take orders.
Especially from you.
But I'm not here to fight you either.
I'm collecting the emeralds to find my own answers.
So why don't you just back off?
See, the moment I started being good, Sonic started
following me.
Because he's like, being good is cool.
What the fuck?
I get a boss fight right at the start?
Um, Sonic, we're about to fucking die.
Black Bull.
That is wild.
What am I supposed to do?
Sonic, Sonic, you wanted this fight.
What the fuck is his weak spot?
I don't fucking know Sonic.
Sonic, what is his weak spot?
Hit it?
Do I just hit it?
Oh, I'm so fucking fast.
I can't touch him.
I legitimately just can't touch him.
I guess what?
Oh my god.
It's the weak spot gun.
I'm so sad I'm
That's fine How do I get his eye?
Do I go?
Oh Wait, what?
Okay, I would assume like There we go
Oh, okay, that's...
Okay, I figured it out.
I just gotta get to a corner.
Rockin'.
Sonic, let me use your body and jump on you!
Alright.
I guess I have to use these guys, right?
Come on, get over here.
Actually, I'll grab a gun.
Can I just...
Can I just do like this?
Wait, let's do anything.
Oh my god, a cheater.
Yeah Jesus Christ I'm too fast.
Where is like enemies that I could use?
Okay, punch this Do I use these guys to jump?
Oh It does okay Oh it did damage okay I don't trust it Oh
Yeah, yeah, it does like so little though Come on, look at
me.
Oh, not like that.
Okay, it does so little Freeze There you go Wait, is that
easy?
That's our Where do you go?
Wait, where do you go?
What?
Wait a minute Wait, where did he go?
Okay, what?
How did he get over here?
Oh, what?
What the fuck?
Okay, that was a scab.
How the fuck did he get over there?
What the fuck?
Magic?
Like, I know, I was like, where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh shit, what the fuck was this attack?
Yeah, how did he move in my frozen world?
It was supposed to be frozen.
How do I kill him now?
Oh there.
Oh shit, not there.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I'm hitting him.
Am I hitting him?
Am I...
Oh, I am, I am, I am.
Okay, that's good, that's good.
I'm just spabbing it.
This is, like, the best I could do.
There we go.
I see the little red glowy thing.
Where is he going?
Oh, he turned around.
It's cheating.
What the fuck, you cow?
And you know you're about to die.
God damn.
Coward!
Oh, you're so dead, you're so close.
Yeah!
End of the line!
Yeah, I know I was so scared of falling off again.
I swear to God, there is no invisible walls.
Everything is like a bottomless pit.
You make one move and you're like, fucking in hell.
We did it.
We defeated the Black Bull.
Yeah!
E4i.
Hello, Mr. President!
Oh, it's like our photo!
Mr. President, we've received a report from the Central
Information Agency.
My best friend, the President.
...successfully pushed back the black aliens from
Westopolis.
We've also managed to suppress enemy forces in five other
cities.
We did it!
...also reports that the CIA's mainframe has been
compromised.
USA, USA, USA.
committed by the black alien tell the commanding generals
that the united federation will never surrender to
terrorists that's right don't worry your best friends here
this planet was once saved from tyranny and annihilation by
you two heroes that's us mankind must protect this peace at
all costs these are my favorite funny animals i love them
like my own family against these invaders it's just like I
don't need a wife I got I got Sonic and shadow
all right oh where am I the circus how did I get to the
fucking circus oh tails hey tails tails he
said the thing
brings back a chaos emerald whoa oh oh do you think he'll be
okay he'll be fine his tails can help him fly easy guess
it's my lucky day he set the line yeah the most lethal what
the fuck all right what's the good side let's take okay
let's take back all of the stolen Okay.
Okay, guys, we cannot die.
This is going to be the hardest good mission of my life.
Oh, no.
Slow and steady.
Guys, because you don't understand.
You don't understand.
We got to get 400.
I can't die.
We gotta power walk through this.
This power walk time.
Gotta go slow.
You know the theme is singing.
But on my own.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
This is how you do it?
All right.
Wait, wait.
Can I do more?
Oh, God.
I'm scared.
I'm trying to make sure I don't die Oh shit Oh shit Oh god
Oh god gotta go slow Gotta go slow yes
I think the worst part Oh nice 20 rings right off the bat
Let's go Wait does that mean if I hit to this one, I can get
more rings?
Okay.
Oh.
This one has to give me another 20, right?
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oh.
Alright, that's good.
That's good.
We got more ammo.
If you use a shooting gallery, hit the clock display to
release the balloons.
By shooting down enough balloons, you can get a bunch of
rings oh tails you can't do this to me tails tails you can't
tails you can't do this to me tails oh my there's no actual
aim at this oh god oh god oh tails why tails why
okay slow and steady I hate you I hate you, Tails so much I,
why would this be a why is money the good mission
oh god oh god oh god
oh god i'm so scared please tell me there's more ammo here
okay all right oh no oh no i don't know how i'll kill him oh
my god oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
i can't die Green is good.
I have a bonus.
No!
My coins.
My rings.
Oh my god.
No, it's still possible.
Guys, it's still possible, guys.
It's still possible.
Just leave.
This is safe.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
What is going on?
No, I don't!
Oh my gosh, I got it.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're helping.
Okay, okay, we got this.
What?
Oh!
Oh my!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh no.
You can jump through that coop of fire.
You'll learn some rings.
Thank you, Tails.
Shadow!
Do you think can grind along this road thank you okay we got
back about half of them i think you can get the rest
okay let's get rid of these guys first
okay yeah me too i feel very safe right now there you go
there you go there you go and then suck What do you think we
can get the rest of them?
Oh my god, this is so cruel, Tails.
This is so cruel.
Why would you do this to me?
Tails, this is why no one wants to be good.
Oh,
I fucked up.
It's okay.
There we go.
We saved it.
Everything is fine.
If you hit the middle of that device dead center with enough
force, you'll get maximum height.
If you can ring the gong at the top, you'll get a bunch of
rings.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Are you?
I leave.
We suck.
We suck here.
And then we leave.
We leave.
It's not worth it.
Make sure to hold on to your weight.
You say?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's...
Oh, it is so funny.
For this shooting game, yellow balloons are worth twice as
much as the red one.
But shooting the ones with eggnog on them will take away
points, so don't hit those final shots.
Okay, that's fine.
There's another shooting gallery board.
It's okay.
Guys, it's okay.
Where are the balloons?
I didn't know the balloons was through the...
I didn't know.
I...
Oh.
My god.
that turret is so cool
i'm getting him out of here first
i i've never i i i don't understand
terrible death to all who oppose me when you stick to the
wall angle jump you can run forward a little we've only got
about two seconds before you fall though so be extra careful
goodbye please oh oh maybe maybe
okay maybe maybe maybe I
Maybe Maybe Maybe
Oh No He can't do this to me Okay
Oh Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I hate that you're...
Oh, thank you.
Sorry, Doctor.
I got no time for games.
Oh, my God.
Thank God I'm so scared.
I got, I thought I was going to get five and then I would
leave one more ring and it was over.
Oh, thank God.
That was the hardest one.
That was the hardest level for me.
If we're easy.
Our sector B3 are reporting to the black aliens have
successfully been driven out of Westophilus.
Why black?
Who wrote this game?
Well done, Kevin.
Oh, crap, this game!
Sir, we think Shadow escaped into the forest with the black
aliens.
Why are they so insid- like- I'm authorizing full use of all
tactical weapons.
I want both black aliens and Shadow stopped and buried.
Failure is not an option.
Yes, sir.
It's over, Shadow.
You'll finally be exposed to humanity.
whoa whoa there this sound it's just doesn't sound right god
bro i just don't like like it's just weird that they're
emphasizing it too
where what the fuck is all right oh hey hey ross
Oops!
Escape from the forest.
Oh hey!
Rude!
My sexy bad girlfriend!
Alright.
God, I hate the sound effect for that is like gross as hell.
Okay, we gotta grab.
What's this gun?
What the fuck is this gun?
Oops, I...
I mean, it doesn't really mean matter if i kill civilians it
doesn't count towards evil at least look it doesn't count
towards evil if i kill the civilian so it should be okay
whoops at least i don't have to worry about fucking dying
hold out fire okay we gotta get you out of here look just
look see he wants to shoot me all right up i go not where's
my oh there she is yeah i was gonna say aren't you gonna
like oh it's okay damn not here it was not okay it was not i
hate i hate how like there is like nearly i hate it so much
there's really like one wrong oh she kicked him oh my god he
she's actually helping oh my god I'll grab that.
I'll do this again.
That's awkward.
Like, I didn't mean to kill the civilians, it's just that
they're there, you know?
They're literally there.
Whee!
Alright, nice.
That's right, oh.
Nice.
all right yeah they're just you know they were there what
was I supposed to do about it you know like I didn't want to
shoot them they were just there okay I got to grab the
checkpoint before I oh my gosh fuck it treading it treading
it treading it treading it I'm still treading I'm still all
right there you go oh shit sorry don't get over confident
all right we gotta grab that and then back to shredding back
to looking cool as heck let's go let's go shredding so
fucking hot oh my god there's so many aliens out of the kill
all right and then the children as well but i make sure we
got the kids too
all right nice we
the kids no no not the fast travel no wait where are they oh
no oh i'm too fast i'm too fast okay it's okay we'll slowly
walk back okay that that is very unfortunate um give me a
sec i gotta figure this out how to go back uh oh okay all
right let's just i guess we go forward for it it's It's
fine, it's fine.
We'll just find a checkpoint, guys.
We can... We'll just find a checkpoint.
It's okay, we can find a checkpoint, guys.
It's still... It's salvageable.
Hang on to the bar and take out the aliens as you find them.
There you are.
Are these aliens?
Okay, we gotta get rid of them just for the fun of it.
Is it the checkpoint?
What?
Checkpoint?
Okay, where's the checkpoint guys?
Checkpoint don't go Hello?
Checkpoint?
I'm still waiting for the checkpoint
That's fine We got it.
Oh, wait, we gotta grab this Guys, I don't know where the
checkpoint wait wait, I don't think I need to come back I
think we're five I just need 10 more.
Surely there's like 10 of them just lying there, right?
Guys, where's the checkpoint?
I still have yet to find guys, but why have I not found a
single checkpoint?
That's actually...
That's actually so crazy that I managed to miss.
Are you fucking... No.
Oh my God, hey, there's checkpoint.
Oh my God.
Okay.
It's okay.
There's...
There's a checkpoint though.
Oh my god, I missed a checkpoint here too.
Alright, surely, surely we got it.
That's an alien, right?
Nice.
Oh, the checkpoint was right behind us!
Let's go!
Okay.
We need five.
Just five.
Surely... Oh, nice.
You five!
One more!
Behold!
The awesome at power!
Oh my god, one more.
Take this!
Okay, you get out of here.
I need a fight.
There you go.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
We won't let you get away.
I won't let you get away with trying to invade this planet.
For your Sandy, do the evil mission for this level.
Unless you want to play one of the worst...
Oh, wait, what do you mean?
Wait, no.
Why didn't I read this before?
Oh, no.
Why didn't I read it before I completed it?
I can't think of this super chat thing.
Thank you.
Are we?
What a pit of a bunch.
What'd you say?
It's a good thing you didn't do the good mission, right?
on the contrary it's over what is he talking about what are
you saying
he's lying don't listen to him tomorrow shadow you should
rest tomorrow i have to wait 24 hours wait did i kill him
you scum you're going down
What do you mean tomorrow?
Oh, I have to fight him again?
I don't know how fucking kill him!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, why am I so fast here?
I'm trying I'm trying!
I can't hit it!
Oh, there you go.
I'm grinding, I'm grinding, I'm grinding.
Oh my god.
I swear to God, I'm so confused.
I'm so confused.
I don't know why I won't hit it.
There you go.
How did I kill him?
Like how do I am I supposed to kill this guy?
Like how?
I'm I swear to God I swear to God hit the fucking grind Oh
my god.
I'm going crazy I'm actually going crazy.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
I don't understand.
I don't.
Oh my god.
I...
I'm so confused.
I'm so confused, guys.
Please, please, I beg of you.
Please, just hit...
Yeah, no, I'm trying.
I swear to God, I'm trying so hard.
When I jump, it doesn't do it.
It doesn't even hit it naturally.
Oh, my God, I hate this.
I hate this.
I...
Give me your gun.
Jump and don't move.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my, give me your gun.
Give me your gun.
This, this is the worst boss fight I've ever seen.
This is the worst one.
This is, I, I found it.
I would, I, I found it.
I'm like doing nothing too.
Oh my god, I, oh.
Where are you in?
Okay, oh my god, I found it.
Oh my god, I found it.
I found it.
I'm so sad.
There we go.
Oh my god, there we go.
Never mind.
This is not the worst part.
This is not the worst boss.
It is not the worst boss.
I didn't realize you just jump and shoot.
There's no way.
There we go.
A moment someone's like, just jump and shoot.
Everything clicked together.
Everything clicked.
Oh, all right.
Time for the quote-unquote worst mission of all time,
apparently.
Now the worst part is here.
Why is it so hard to be good?
Why does being good cause so much pain?
Hey, Sonic.
Not you again Nice to see you too Looks like those black
creatures are headed out to space We're on our way to the
Ark So I guess that means we're going to Oh In the evil
level they said I destroyed it And I was like what the fuck
What the fuck is the Ark
Yay to space we go
Whoa Whoa that looks like a dev star you've got to be
kidding me guys this is like taking candy from a baby which
is fine by me what okay shadow that powers the literal
literal ship shadow are you fucking stupid what bro he just
fucking punched the glass help me maria maria please shadow
i need your help my grandfather's experiments something's
gone horribly wrong what is it the research lab it's going
to speak done is there a lower reason that he did this is he
stupid i'll be there maria don't worry whatever it takes
i'll take care of the ark and the He's gonna do that thing
Like he would punch a baby to steal that candy.
Oh, hey Maria All right, I'm worried about the perfect
defeat the artificial chaos.
How do I destroy it?
I have a human following me.
I don't know if that's safe.
I don't feel safe knowing that she's following me
Oh, I have to destroy these okay I All right.
Yeah, that's a fast-ass human.
Thank God your grandpappy stored a lot of guns around here.
You can get through tight spaces by sliding.
Oh, I didn't see this.
Thank goodness for that.
I'm glad your grandpa has a well-stocked armory.
Whoa.
Sorry, I shot the wrong
Actually shot the humans Oh, it's okay, Maria I'm fine if
you want to know Alright, let's see I'm fine, though, Maria
We gotta grab this Damn, not here Okay, okay I didn't
realize that It's a pit down there, but That's good to know.
That's good to know now.
That's good.
That's good to know.
That's a pit.
Underneath that.
It's good.
It's good information.
I'm glad that you told me right on time.
I'm so happy.
There it is.
The artificial chaos is out of its own.
Am I shooting it?
Yeah, I am.
They're multiple.
Do you think we should see this place?
No, I want their guns.
No, I need their guns.
I need a reload.
What's gun is this?
Oh, yeah, no, I'll take this.
I'll keep the pistol.
Are you serious?
Who are you shooting?
Who are you?
There.
You deserve that.
Oh, my God.
Do I have?
Okay, there's a checkpoint.
Oh, my God.
There was a checkpoint right there.
I'm so sad.
No, we don't need this.
We just need more gun
I'm being very careful right now Maria Very very careful
Oh, what do you mean?
Thank merciful modern You mean it could have been much much
more worse How?
Oh my oh my
Thank God Thank God they give me mercy
There you go Thank God there is mercy in this world
Alright Are there Where am I?
Where the?
Where am I?
You call yourself gun soldiers Like where are they?
Oh there it is All right, there they are.
Oh my god, I have to find all three.
Oh my god, get out, get out, get out.
There you go.
Give me your gun.
Instead of 35.
I like how the five is like, makes such a big difference.
You guys are like, thank God it's not 35.
And that worries me.
That makes me scared.
The experiments are fusing together.
What?
Is there anything up here?
That scares me.
That five makes a huge difference.
That actually scares me a lot.
So you guys don't worry, it's five.
Oh my god, where?
Oh, I'm supposed to go up.
All right.
Here we go.
Wait, it's not here?
Where the fuck am I supposed to- Oh my god, I'm already
lost.
I'm already lost in this fucked up world.
Oh my god, I don't know.
I don't know where I'm supposed to go.
I don't know what they're talking about, guys.
This was like level with a cakewalk.
Then where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Like, is there, like, Is there a secret hole here?
Where is it?
Like, where am I?
Okay, okay.
Calm down, Doki.
There's a pull here.
We're suffering severe casualties.
Maybe I climb up the pull?
That's right, Shadow.
Work it.
Work that pull, Shadow.
You go, girl.
It was not the pull.
We got to slide down like a fireman now.
Whoa.
That's right.
Whoa, Shadow.
Whoa.
Work that pull.
Can we hit the mutated experiments with a gunlift?
Damn, Shadow.
You know how to work that pull, bro?
Gotta pay that college tuition somehow.
I'm just gonna slowly walk down.
I don't trust myself at all.
Where else am I supposed to go?
What?
Okay.
At least I figured it out.
All right.
Wait, wait.
Was that experiment?
No, that was just a regular guy.
Okay.
Okay, we got another one.
Let's get him out of here.
I mean, they're all sort of dead already, so we should be
good.
Is there any extra here?
Oh, no.
Not just for the sake of it.
Snackies!
Maybe I accidentally shot somebody.
Buy products based on a god
Is there anything missing here?
I'm scared.
I'm so paranoid right now I know I'm like checking
everything.
I'm so fucking paranoid, but where did I come I came from
this way.
Okay Thank you Maria All right, we're good.
We're good.
Go in
Okay We got an experiment Jesus Christ.
It is like actually like hide-and-seek right now.
Oh, are they hiding anywhere?
Oh, where are you?
There's no... Okay, there it is.
I was gonna say there's no way there's just one of them
here.
I'm literally playing hide-and-seek with these guys.
Alright, nice.
We're not even halfway.
That's... That's okay.
That's okay.
It's fine that we're not Okay.
Alright.
Okay, we got another checkpoint.
Thank God.
Elevators here.
Phew.
Oh, God.
Okay, I almost got crushed.
That's fine.
We didn't get crushed.
We didn't get crushed, guys.
Alright.
Up we go.
Uh.
Where could he be?
If I was a fucked-up experiment, where would I be?
Oh, okay.
It's time to work that pull again, Shadow.
Let's go!
Woo!
Oh, shit, you're over here.
Give me a sec.
There you go, we got it.
That's right.
Work it.
Wow, chicko-wow-wow.
Is there anything else up here?
They were good.
Right?
Oh, there's more.
Hello, guys.
You guys call for...
Is it somebody's birthday?
I heard it's somebody's birthday.
Oh, not you.
Am I shooting it?
I think so.
Oh, my God.
You guys are so annoying.
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
I'm going to shoot.
You guys do.
You guys mess with me.
You guys mess with the Groove!
That's right.
I am willing to waste my ammo.
Oh, hey guys.
What the fuck?
There's nothing here.
But there's nothing here.
Why is there a room?
It was Keith's birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
you throw it down everything else here yeah bro is guarding
an empty room like nobody trusted this man to guard anything
so he they're like don't worry bro this is a very important
room trust me it is so important you guarding it is life or
death Hey, where do I go?
Oh, here.
Which way do we go?
Oh, my God, Maria, please.
Don't you live here?
Should you know where to go, Maria?
You literally live here.
Your dad is the CEO of this fucking lab.
I'm just gonna shoot it.
Oh.
You think I can bounce off of it?
I did it but she did say I could carry it oh shit wait how
do I get back to the other side oh no oh wait I fucked up oh
no oh that's bad oh I think that's a pit right okay that's
fine okay damn not here There being another entryway Okay,
it's fine It's fine, it's okay We can do this again
It's okay, it's okay guys It's okay, we can do this again I
got another gun
Okay, there was like what?
Two, right?
Check your dick We'll hold out here
All right.
One down.
Just gotta slowly climb up.
It's okay.
I heard it's someone's birthday again.
I heard it.
Who's the lucky guy?
Oh, no.
Okay, I got...
I need you to give me your gun.
Bro.
There you go.
Okay, that's awkward.
Give me a sec.
You don't understand.
It's actually very hard to aim with this.
Guys, you don't understand.
It's very hard to aim with it.
No, you don't understand, guys.
It was so hard to aim with it.
I swear to God.
Okay, there you go.
It's fine.
I got another...
I'm gonna kill him.
All right, we can try this again.
There, see?
I did it.
And that's still your gun, too.
See, told you guys.
See, I did it.
I did it.
It wasn't that high.
this again.
It's not.
It's okay.
We got this.
So now that I have this, I can just kill him.
You can use that experiment to bounce off it using your
homing attacks, but it's very dangerous.
There we go.
We don't have to go back there.
That was a trap.
That area was a fucking trap.
We can't go back there.
I hit it?
That Oh god.
Did I hit it?
Okay, I hit.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
There, see, I did.
Oh, shit!
I need another gun.
Give me your gun.
This is easier.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Give me your gun.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Oh my god, where am I?
is this?
I get that.
What the fuck is that sound?
You could have just passed, Loki.
Look, I'm too scared of confrontation.
If I kill them, I never have to ask.
Whoops.
Well, they're die regardless, unfortunately.
I mean, it's like, those people are gonna die, Sonic, if you
don't save them.
I'm like, um, yeah, um, unfortunately they may or may not be
dead but it's not because of me.
This part, but, I went the other way because I thought
they're, I thought it was a dead end.
The gun soldiers have been taken down by the research and
spear
Oh, hey.
Oh, they're all down.
Don't worry, I got you, guys.
Oh, whoops.
It's okay.
I know what to do.
Watch this, guys.
Yay.
Oh, nice checkpoint.
Okay, I'm going to go back upstairs.
There must be another path for this, right?
Wait, where's the...
I don't know why I'm max evil.
I'm hoping.
What did I do wrong?
Oh, shit.
Where am I?
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't know what's causing me to...
I don't know.
I'm just as equally as confused as you guys.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad I'm where how where am I like actually where am I
oh my god I'm back here oh okay uh guys I don't remember how
to okay it's this way it's this way all right we go this way
and then we go this way and then we TP
no Okay, and then we hit him again and hit him again.
There you go.
Snow and steady, guys.
As in all Sonic games.
Okay.
We go this way.
And then we go this way.
And then it's this way.
And it would be very helpful if I had a gun right now.
You know what?
I wish I didn't remember Maria.
No!
Don't say it, guys.
Don't say it.
Okay, that was on.
This is why Shadow forgot Maria.
I wish I suppressed my...
No wonder he suppressed his memory of Maria.
Okay.
If I drop from...
Here.
It should be fine.
There you go.
Oh my god, I saw a missed accident.
Don't fuck this.
Get out of here!
Boom!
Alright, I did it.
Third time's the try.
How do I...
Oh my god, and it gave me a gun.
And of course, it gave me a gun when I never needed it.
Alright.
Just for that one guy, it was worth it.
It was so worth it.
Oh my god, there's still eight more.
There's still eight more of this hellhole.
The thing is, I can't die or I have to do that again.
Oh, this is the worst part.
The worst part is I can't die.
Because I don't know where the next checkpoint is.
Where is he?
No.
Oh my god, please tell me it's shooting him.
Oh my god, it's all the way back there.
Oh my god, please.
Please, but I love God.
No!
Oh, I can go back.
Thank God.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
checkpoint, checkpoint, checkpoint, checkpoint, checkpoint,
checkpoint.
checkpoint where's the checkpoint checkpoint checkpoint wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute where's the checkpoint wait a minute
wait a minute where the fuck is the checkpoint guys
oh there it is there it is there it is i just didn't see it
okay there's three more check all right there's still a hole
oh thank god i could i didn't think it was i was
Oh my god, I didn't take a single shot.
Oh my god, oh my god, I still need...
Okay, that's fine, it's fine, we still made it.
It's okay, it's still, it's still made it.
We're almost there.
Alright, nice, okay.
Four more, four more, four more, four more.
Well, there you go.
Okay, more and more to go.
More and more to go, guys.
I can smell freedom.
Oh my god, now I have to worry about meteors.
What the fuck is wrong with your dad?
Why are there...
Why are there no defense mechanisms for these fucking
meteors?
They're not supposed to be this close to the ship.
This is not safe.
This is not a safe place for children
I didn't even see a single fucking experiment here I'm
fucking leaving Fuck this, there was no experiment here I
was lied to I went out here for nothing Oh my god Okay,
okay, okay Alright, that's fine, that's okay
Alright, okay Nope, there was, never mind, JK JK Guys, guys,
guys, he ran into me.
It's like a deer, okay?
I did not commit a hit or run.
He ran into me.
We all saw it, guys.
We all saw the experiment running into my car like a deer.
Maria, they're trying to kill me.
What the fuck?
They're multiplying at an extreme rate.
I haven't even seen one of them yet.
Where are they multiplying?
Holy shit.
Oh, whoops.
That was whoops.
That's awkward.
Oh,
there you go.
28.
Nice.
All right, down I go.
Free gun.
Wow.
Look at that.
It's funny that someone left a gun there.
Oh, it's so silly
So silly guys
Can't believe they would leave like a properly working gun
just sitting there in the open
Yeah, so this way Oh my god, I'm trying my best Maria.
I swear to God
Okay.
Wait, wait.
There might be the 20th, 30th right here, somewhere.
The 30th is here lurking around.
Right here.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Alright, last guy.
I mean, there's still five more, but we don't...
We'll let the soldiers worry about that.
Yay!
Yeah, I almost ran into the ring there.
Thank God I had self-control.
I will protect the professor and the ark.
yeah oh my god that that level alone took me 26 minutes of
fucking hide and seek
oh maria oh my god did we push her out into space did she
got voted off oh no she's still in the heart your help
everyone's fate depends on maria what happened
were you E for erasing evidence so I was just like who's
that buddy what is that?
what is that?
once every 50 years that black comet passes by this planet
oh do you think those black creatures are somehow just
because the comet is black doesn't mean everyone comes from
it sonic I think you're right I feel it.
They're up there.
That's where the answers are.
I've got to get to that.
Oh my god.
Am I also...
Is that also from there too?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Last level.
How do you unlock the true ending after that?
Guys, please don't tell me I have to play this again.
Guys.
I am actually not strong enough to play this a fourth time,
guys.
I...
Guys, I'm sorry.
i actually am not strong find black dude the big boss is the
big boss is inside oh we won't tell it okay find black dude
oh my god like i got shot and shot so i just like you okay
everybody i'm just standing there fuck this i need the gun i
need your gun I cannot be bothered.
I need your gun.
If I have to deal with this.
Alright.
Are you serious?
Okay, okay.
These guys.
Okay, I was going to say.
I swear to God, I have to go all the way back to kill all of
them.
That would have been nice to know, Sonic.
Yahoo!
The aliens have decided to send in the best of the best That
weird alien weapon can suck up wings It looks like it works
just by I'm grabbing this
Suck That's right Oh, that doesn't work for that Okay, I
leave now Sayonara I think we might be able to pull
something out of this What?
How?
What the fuck?
How do I get out of here?
I actually have to kill these?
Oh my god, Sonic actually helped.
Give me out of here.
Oh, thank god.
Fast travel!
Wow!
Nice.
I don't know how I got here.
Oh,
thank god.
I don't have to think for myself.
It's the black creature.
There's some of that red alien slime stuff on the wall.
Damn.
Not here.
Did I get a checkpoint?
No, I did not.
Alright.
Here we go again.
Here we go.
And I did not.
I did not unlock a checkpoint.
I hit the wolf because of course.
I did it.
Let's go.
Oh god, it's like an egg sack.
What the fuck?
It's like I'm holding a fucking egg sack.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I hear you.
I assume that I just gotta kill him, right?
Now Now what?
Now where the fuck do I go?
What?
Now grab this.
Oh shit wait this gun is better.
Shoot the cube?
Oh shoot this?
What?
Oh use the suck?
Oh!
Oh, give me your gun.
Alright, it's suck time.
Oh!
Okay, I figured it out, guys.
Give me your fucking...
I need... I need reload.
Oh, that's cool.
Okay, that is actually a neat concept.
They finally introduced something new.
Wait, I want more of the fast travel.
me that fast travel.
I would say that is a unique, a neat utility, a neat ability
that they introduce.
God, that is so, I just don't like the sound effect for
that.
Oh, is that it?
Here?
In here?
Sonic, what the fuck?
You want me to go this way?
Oh, here!
Is that black doom?
Oh.
Yeah, no shit is a fate.
There we go.
Nice.
The ultimate power.
The ultimate power!
Oh, okay, I'm here now.
Okay.
Where's the other one?
Green for a gamer.
Thank God for fast travel.
Oh, and thank God for checkpoint.
I was so scared.
It's okay.
They're like, come forth giants and stop him.
And then I just walk past him.
Like, what giant?
I just casually walk past all the fucking giants.
Yay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We got the checkpoint.
It's okay.
Nothing to worry about.
It's not too much.
We're not too far.
We're not too far from progress.
Maybe I can casually just... Ah, fuck it.
I'm too lazy.
We do not just throw right at.
Why did you not jump on the other?
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
People make mistakes.
We can do this again.
There we go.
See?
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I swear to god if I didn't grab that check foot.
You know, everyone makes mistakes.
What the fuck?
Who's that guy in there?
Who is he?
It doesn't matter.
He must not be that important.
Yeah, he's not that important, right?
Come on.
It's okay.
Okay, nice.
I got it.
Oh, shit.
What's that?
All right, nice.
Got more ammo?
Oh, hey.
I got the suck.
The suck gun.
Where do I go now?
Oh, this is.
Oh, not like this.
Who do I?
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's what I suck.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, hey.
I'll grab this suck gun.
This is a better suck.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Here?
Yay!
Am I doing it?
Okay.
Okay, this way.
And then...
Thanks, Dad, for teaching me how to kill you.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for teaching me how to kill you, Dad.
Oh, yeah, I'm waiting for you, too.
Suck.
Alright, this way.
Okay.
All right, this is where I...
This is where I kill my dad.
Ow!
Yeah, I don't think this is a human weapon.
This definitely does not look like a human weapon.
Oh, shit!
Okay, never mind.
Wait, how do I...
Where do I go?
Oh, it's over here.
And then...
This way?
I am so lost, guys.
guys what
oh oh here oh my god i'm so lost i am very lost right now
i'm just gonna go fast
yeah i did i like how he's like backseeding me too but where
do i go after that oh this way here
all right nice this way down and then fast question mark
fast time I'd suck them all I'm a little concerned with the
fact that like you know oh my god.
That's it.
There you go.
Oh, nice.
Oh, thank God.
I skipped everything here.
Oh, this level is so long.
Oh, my God.
All right.
How many checkpoints?
Oh, my God.
There's still two more checkpoints.
Oh, my I was not expecting how the fact that this is
considered a massive I'm gonna try I need more fast travel I
did two skips two skips and I'm still here
all right wait where where do I
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
I'm still fine.
He didn't actually hit me, apparently.
Uh, is that everybody?
Oh, don't!
I'm alive.
I don't know.
Oh, it's him.
He hit me.
It's okay, everybody.
I'm fine.
There I go.
Maybe it's up this way.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I almost had it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, That was close.
That was very close.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, is that him?
There he is.
Sonic, we did it!
We made it!
Don't fall.
That was so close.
I almost fell.
I actually almost fell.
So, we meet at last, Black Doom.
You're the one responsible for all this villain.
That's me.
E for everyone.
for easy okay here we go it's the final countdown you've
done well shadow i'm very impressed you made it this far
black doom your rule ends here and it ends now that's right
i'm good now like it or not the game's over e for yeah
awesome the black arms are more than superior we are perfect
do you really think you have any real chance of defeating us
it's you who should be scared black that's right i made a
promise to maria to save the planet she loved yeah i got my
memory back then get ready to die let me show you the
ultimate power in the You can't have the ultimate power if
I'm the ultimate life form.
Shadow, who the fuck is Maria?
Okay, Shadow, okay, Sonic, how do we...
How do we kill him?
Sonic, how do we kill him?
Oh, that's how.
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, he did something... he teleported.
That's cheating.
boy he's cheated he teleported oh my god are you fucking are
you kidding me all right where is he okay there he is all
right nice this is so stupid this is okay it's fine all
right where is he
that's right you're on low ground now what you gotta do what
wait wait what how did he hit back make sure to get out of
the way that's right you're on low ground again what you
gotta do about that no hot ground to stop me are you fucking
kidding Why are you just sitting there?
Like, why are you like...
Bro, you're back on high ground, bro.
This ain't a fight.
This ain't a challenge anymore.
This is just sad.
You can dodge that light blade boomerang thing by jumping
over it.
Alright, nice.
At least he started going on high ground.
I got a little sad about it.
Hey, can I...
Okay, nice.
There's a red box.
Yeah, what is this?
this red box, actually.
Is this a gun?
Oh, I could have used a gun this entire time?
Alright, that's it.
It's over.
It's over now that I know.
Wait.
Why did none of my bullets hit him?
Wait a minute.
Got another gun.
Where is he?
What?
That's it.
Where is he?
Okay.
This is like the worst one.
Wait, where did he go?
excuse me you cannot teleport away when I'm fucking when
you're frozen how do you teleport away when you're frozen
what does that even mean
oh my god I hate you so much
oh my god this is so tedious do i have any more i used to
block the guns how does this game make stop time look so
late i don't understand how did it not stop time
oh my god please please
Oh, there's one more box.
Where's the last box?
Wait.
Let's just hit him one more time.
Oh my god, there it is.
Just please be a good box.
Oh no, not this gun.
Is it hitting?
I...
Did she even hit him?
It hit him.
god okay okay oh my god it's me me and two rings one more
hit one more hit there we go
all right there we go we did it we killed her dad me and my
two rings this planet i will not let you And two rings and a
dream.
We did it, guys.
Sonic was there.
We did it!
And he was there.
Boom, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
The Suckum is a reference to Billy Hatchin, a giant egg.
Oh, I love that game.
I had that game growing up.
It's fun.
I don't really remember much about it.
I just like rolling the egg.
I got all the chaos emeralds.
Sonic was like, I got off.
I.
The city don't bring us to be weak.
Let's do this.
I'm Shadow the Hedgehog.
And I made a promise that I intend to keep.
With the power of these emeralds, Black Doom and his army
are finished.
This is who I am.
Yay!
Drag!
Thank you!
Welcome to Tamayefi!
Welcome- that's how it- this is who I am!
So did we like save the world?
Like...
Oh no!
That's crazy that they made like a song for each ending.
And you're all like pretty good too.
Oh my god.
Guys How do you get true ending before I Guys I don't know
if I'm strong enough for a fourth time
So so the mod it allows Oh it appears on the menu Oh thank
god oh thank god Okay okay Oh thank god okay it's just it's
a menu thank God because I don't know if I'm strong I don't
know how you how the kids did it getting all ten endings
thank God oh thank God
yeah I know it's like the rituals game it was just I don't
know how people did it to get all ten
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, no.
found a meeting that you searched for so long.
Oh, hell's shadows.
Oh, no, bum, bum.
No, bum, bum,
God, is this so edgy?
Oh my god, Shreddy Guitar Man!
You go, Guitar Man!
Shadow!
Woo!
The anthem of...
It gets me every time.
It just... I don't know.
It just gets me every time.
Last story on the...
I see the light.
Oh my god, I see the light.
It's there.
It's actually there.
There's actually a light in this whole 50-year return of the
black comet.
At last I see the light.
Finally, I've got all the chaos emeralds.
Now, I can uncover the truth about my past.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Didn't I kill you?
Give me the chaos emeralds.
Wait, I never, Amy never showed up in my playthrough.
Do not give the emeralds to black doom, Shadow.
I was like, where did Amy come from?
Ignorant fools.
We're here to save the humans from their own demise.
We offer salvation.
I told you.
See, the aliens are the good guys.
We were trying to help the humans.
This ring has them on a path of self-destruction.
Wait, cream the rabbits in this game too?
The extinction of their species.
We're here to save them from themselves.
I guess she wasn't invited to the chaos meeting.
He sounds like such a good person.
Oh, so it's like a zoo.
Well, he did specify humans.
So like the hedgehogs are safe.
The animals are safe.
Wait, how did Shadow just let him take the chaos just like
that?
I like how he just let it happen.
Oh?
Is the president okay?
What just happened?
Those black creatures just warped the comet down to the
surface using chaos control.
Ah!
No, that's impossible.
The comet wasn't black either, it was red.
Chaos Emeralds.
Precisely.
The comet's velocity isn't powerful enough to pass through
another planet.
atmosphere whoa sonic you can't just say that
we need them to charge the full power it's the perfect plan
that's why i needed the professor to help me what what
that's insane maria igman's like what no that's not me yeah
he thinks he's the only for doctor slash professor the
professor was in development of the ultimate life force but
he needed my help so we made a deal i helped him and he
promised to deliver me the seven chaos emeralds that's how
you were created shadow you would help us to boom that's me
Eggman thinks he's part of the team.
Yeah, I'm like, we invited...
We invited Eggman, but not Kareem the Ravid?
That can't be.
He betrayed his own people for research.
For black...
Okay, Dr. Eggman.
You can't...
Okay.
He can't just stand there doing nothing.
Yeah.
Let's do this.
Okay.
Um...
A bit of a hypocrite there.
Knuckles, what's wrong?
Oh!
a special weapon this gas once released is quickly absorbed
into your bloodstream in a moment total paralysis will hit
your nervous what the end is near now didn't know they're
lagging
ah my dear offspring eat and devour these savory dishes oh
Help me!
Who after Eggman first, he has more meat?
Did I...
Did I?
What?
That's why you were created.
Please help me, Shadow.
What the fu- what?
What?
With the power of Maria.
I have shadow of Hedgehog.
I've left the past behind me.
The power of edginess and Maria.
I will destroy you, Black Doom.
Black.
I gave you your life.
And this is how you repay me.
Just say no.
I gave you life.
Bro, just say.
that easy just say no and then the and then the fucking
chemicals won't work you're our only hope now bro sucking
kill the other babies what the fuck shadow shadow what okay
okay shadow let's just let them get devoured bro bro just
step on them you have died he just okay Okay, that's
awkward.
That's awkward.
Well, his friends are definitely gonna be dead.
Oh, shit.
He's gonna head straight.
He seems straight as...
What?
Hit me!
Okay.
That's actually crazy that he just left them.
Left them there to get devoured.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, this hurts me, okay, okay, that's,
okay, I, that's just, all right, I had to accept the fact
that this also hurts me.
Oh, why can't I kill it?
I can't even get back up.
Can I?
cat okay there you go oh i'll get out of here oh it's here
oh god confused i damn not here it's okay it's okay i got a
checkpoint i got the checkpoint right here
damn not here it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay there is the light is the i see the light i
oh damn not here ducky it's okay the light is almost there
you're almost at the light there we go there we go there we
go we fly here we go here we go at last i see the light No,
no, no, no.
It's okay there.
You got this flying, man.
You can fly through it all.
It's all right.
I believe in you.
Keep flying.
You can make it.
All right, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I am going to freak out.
All right, here you go.
You're gonna use 25 of your time to beat this.
Oh my god, I just noticed the timer.
I don't know.
Oh no.
What do you mean on time?
What do you mean?
Oh no.
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay we're
almost there right surely we're almost there right it just
means it's timing me in the way that means we're almost
there right guys we're so close to the end shit okay but
also why is it green if it's very oh my god oh my god are
you fucking kidding me why is green why not red to tell me
that this is urgent usually they would make it red for an
sos oh my god where the where's the sock where's the sock
where the is the sock gun
Oh, I'm just going to shoot him.
Just give me your gun.
Oh, my God.
Just get chaos control.
There is the ultimate power.
I have to.
Might as well get ultimate power.
It's the only way.
Are you fucking?
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh my
god.
I need gun.
Gun.
Give me gun.
God, give me this.
I swear to God!
Oh my!
I'm so sad.
Where is another gun that I can use?
Oh my God, you fucker!
Oh my God, no!
it's okay everything is fine okay I need your blaster okay
we got the blaster there we go there we go okay maybe I
could have saved that I definitely could have saved that
where I'm closer but I was very mad I I was... I was very,
very mad.
Oh.
Okay.
You want to...
Alright.
You want to play it like that.
Okay.
Where am I?
Oh my god, it was this way.
Okay, three more minutes.
I gotta, I gotta fucking grab.
I gotta grab more fucking chaos controls here.
I swear to- Okay.
We're almost to another chaos control.
Get over there.
The ultimate power!
Whrrr!
Am I coming free?
Black Doom is waiting for you in the chamber further up
ahead.
Oh, thank God.
for me damn not here
where am i ah i am here ah i am here i am ah i see i i see i
i i see I see where I am.
Ah, guys, I get it.
This game.
Okay, okay, this game.
Okay.
Okay, this game.
This, this game.
No, guys, guys, I can make it.
I can, I can make it.
It's possible.
It's okay.
One minute in a dream.
I will save the world.
Oh my god.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Damn it's okay.
This is possible.
It's still possible.
It's so, so possible.
Please, I just, please, I just, oh my god, please, please,
where is he?
Please, it's right there.
Oh my god.
Black team is waiting for you in the chamber.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, where?
you mean there's more how much more was there oh my god what
do you mean there were more what do you mean how much more
was there to this level Give me the gun.
Give me the gun.
Now that I know how much more there is here.
Now that I know.
Alright.
It's fine.
I realize
this part you ain't getting me again.
You're not.
I'm not letting you don't win this sad
I'm bugged I'm actually bugged oh my oh my okay there we go
there we go there we go there we go I forgot the controls
were inverted I I forgot we forgot back then back then
gamers love and Converted controls because they were
masochists.
Because we didn't know better.
We didn't know better.
We didn't know there were better options.
Oh my god.
That's called speedrun.
I'm keeping it.
I'm keeping the fucking fast travel for now.
It's okay.
We're getting better time, guys.
Time is a lot better this time.
Guys, we're doing it.
Okay.
There we go.
I can skip this.
The ultimate power.
The whole.
Oh, my God.
Keep forgetting.
These guys don't fucking work.
Oh, I forgot about these.
Oh, please.
Please, that's all I asked for.
I don't ask for much.
I just want to hit.
Oh, my God.
Give me your ammo.
Please.
God thank God I'm doing it I'm doing it
behold what that's fucking right that's fucking right that's
right I have ammo for fucking days I farmed it oh my god I
have so much ammo for cut for ultimate power
That's all I'm coming for you.
Okay.
Good time.
Good time, guys.
Oh, fuck.
No, please, please.
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay.
We have good time right now.
I'm going straight over.
I'm not gonna waste this Here we go The only way to get
through KS control Shadow Where the am I coming through?
What am I now?
I'm waiting for you in the chamber further up ahead I'm
gonna fuck it No!
Not here Oh, oh, oh, thank God, okay, okay Okay, I lost I
lost my gun But that's it okay it's okay sometimes sometimes
things gotta sometimes things just gotta happen
it just gotta be like that it just things just gotta be
fucked up like that okay ultimate power all right now we're
down here
Oh my god.
Oh my like what is happening?
What the fuck is what what is happening?
What the fuck is happening?
What?
What is going on?
Like what is going on?
Where is my fuck?
Oh I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'm
like I don't
I don't I don't know if I can.
It's an actual...
It was a fucking war zone.
Oh my...
I chose the wrong gun.
Oh, I chose the wrong gun.
I'm dead.
I have no coins.
I am so dead.
I made it.
I'm not dead.
We did it.
E for not dead.
Zero rings and a dream.
E for alive.
E live.
But you
still don't understand, do you?
The future we offer is the only option for these humans.
I've heard enough.
You're boring me to death, Black Doom.
You're going down.
I remember my homies are okay.
I didn't leave them to get eaten alive.
Um, I'm not little.
I am, like, above average.
I'm colored as Sonic.
I'm more alike than you think.
The same blood runs through all the...
E for edgy.
This can't be...
just who are you don't you know you were created from my
blood what oh yeah I have three dads oh my god he's half
alien half hedgehog no can you escape your past damn you no
it's not true
what the fuck where are they here are you invited these guys
we need you to focus because if we don't hurry all why are
they here easier said than done who signed me up for this
anyway that's it I'll do it get out of the way Get back
here, you idiot!
They're in the game?
Hey!
It's working!
Yay, we did it!
If you understand, I didn't even get to their missions.
I was like, where did Amy get here?
I didn't even get to Amy's mission.
Oh, dad?
Second dad?
You need to know the truth.
The government plans to shut down this racer.
facility for a dad so you count sonic or a shadow the
government plans to cease all of our research and imprison
all who know about you i made a terrible mistake not the
government it's all you knew this press mr president contact
with that comet professor gerald now listen very it feels
like the government didn't even know about this he's there
he's just like what the fuck we were going to seize the
research oh my god these guys are still there they plan to
harness its powers to destroy this planet yeah i don't think
he does to stop them was to develop a way to use the very
power they intended to use against them we did that's it
it's brilliant
I developed the Eclipse Cannon.
It's the only weapon that can destroy that black comet.
Shadow, you are the only...
Yeah, wait a minute.
He's bad, can't move.
The future of this planet depends on you.
Don't worry, Grandfather.
Shadow and I will protect this planet.
Right, Shadow?
Gerald, you fool.
is already in my control what's this psych well well I just
chose to not be controlled by you that's how the mind works
I just say no I now understand why I am here I made a
promise and I'm here to keep it today just say no it's just
that easy.
The power of free will.
So be it.
Be prepared to meet your maker.
Your past, present, and future ends here.
Today.
I was like, if he kills the planet, all the Latinas would
die.
Can't let that happen.
Oh my god, I'm going super saiyan.
works because like he's he's the voice actor of Goku too
well not him but like the evil guy that's actually crazy
that's actually funny but they had the super saiyan concept
and then the main villain is voiced by Goku all hell shadow
what the fuck how do I kill Oh, this guy.
What the?
What?
What do I do?
Wait, open your eyes!
You can get more...
Oh, there he is!
Or how do I get more rings?
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Do these give me rings?
Oh, they do.
Okay, that's his butt.
We gotta go to the front.
I assume that that is butt.
Okay, that's his ass.
His eyes is here.
Okay, I need you to go up.
Alright, you're not gonna be going up.
that's that's five okay he's not going up that's okay that's
okay why can't you understand that the humans are the
parasites of this world absolute oh that's X for me by the
way I was like hold B
Okay Yeah But I'll make sure we don't shoot it Wait, he has
oh, he has two heads.
I thought the other one was that
I think like spamming it is like stronger Only because I do
more damage with spam Look, just because I spam it a lot.
I was going to say, if he has two heads, then like, how does
he, you know, like, use the bathroom, you know?
Ask him the important questions here.
Chaos Control!
What?
You blocked it?
What the fuck is the point?
I can't block this!
Oh,
shit.
Sorry, I was too busy jamming out.
Are you...
Are you fucking...
I'm trying, Sonic!
There you go.
Oh no.
Chaos control!
Where are my rings?
Oh, it's over here.
I head to the rings area.
There you go.
Are you fucking kid- oh my god, okay.
I didn't know where to press I can't move up or down.
I can only move left move left and right so it's like super
annoying
Damn right I am There you go Yeah The ultimate life form
This universe I am the immortal life form I am the ultimate
power Oh, you're such an ultimate life form form how do you
doubt me the true ultimate life form this is the end of you
and the end to my cursed past damn shadow my god be for
beast later loser you're i'm the cooler life form
um i'm ultimate er
Oh shit.
Oh, I sent the comet to their spaceship.
Oh no, to the laser moon.
That's right, get fucking lasered.
A true ultimate life form would have blocked that.
Shadow, that was sweet.
I hope he's okay.
I'm sure he's fine, Rouge.
After all, he is.
shadow how about giving me back those chaos emeralds now hey
get back here you creep oh stop him he's a criminal why are
you laughing
i like to say yes they left that in after the way we all
treated him he saved us all in the end We were all wrong
about him, Professor.
Yeah, bro.
Shouldn't have racial profiled, man.
Let us pay homage to Professor Gerald.
Let's work to ensure peace and prosperity for a brighter
future.
Yeah, you regret that, huh?
What do you say, Commander?
Excellent idea, Mr. President.
Goodbye forever.
Shadow the Hedgehog.
Oh.
Wait, if he's not Shadow the Hedgehog, who would he be?
That's all you are.
That's all you have.
Sayonara's shadow.
And then it took like how many years till the next...
It took like what?
20 plus years till we got another shadow game.
Goodbye.
It's crazy.
It's crazy that this game did not do that well.
Meep, they gave him the 10 gift the ships, thank you.
After playing this game for five hours, I just don't
understand why this game did not do so well.
I wonder why.
It was like, took you, so you're going to do the other seven
endings.
Guys, guys, I love this game.
but like i feel like if i play more um you know you know i
might i don't want to lose my love for it you know i don't
want to get burnt out because i have too much love for the
game you know there were no honestly i don't see i don't see
any cons or like um you know any mistakes that they did
versus like game development wise like game level design or
anything i felt like it was just everything was just so
perfect you know um i mean there are 326 storylines guys
like so much variety that they give us i don't want to play
olive i want to make sure that you guys have a chance
experience it yourself too uh it was like it was truly the
ultimate game just the right amount of edginess yeah yeah
yeah right yeah it would be if i played if i play all the
endings then it'd be too much peak you know there's a limit
to how much peak a game can have rip shadow not enough
latino baddies chat thank you thank you uh space thank you
super chat thing thank you trying to follow this game
neutralize my adder all and set my stomach but it was fun
watching you go through multiple endings i hope your psyche
is okay thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you he doesn't shadow the headshot anymore now he's
shadow the edge lord thank you this super chat thank you
thank you i will say when you were guys were like doki how
could you fuck no you don't understand the controls I felt
like they were fighting me like I wasn't controlling Shadow
Shadow was controlling me I don't understand you never
played this game before you don't understand I true I felt
like I felt like I was I was I was actually having a mental
warfare with the controls
and that just shows how good the game is you know you would
think that you are in control but in the end the game is in
control of you and that's what makes it even better
you have exactly it builds characters you know you have to
be strong to be shadow if you can't conquer the controls you
do not deserve shadow the hedgehog if you can't can't be in
control of the controllers, then play Sonic.
Go for Weedy Hut Jr. and play Sonic the Hedgehog.
You have to earn it.
You have to earn it to play Shadow the Hedgehog.
You gotta control the chaos.
Yeah, go for the If that was developed correctly, like a
fucking casual.
If you cat out of the controls, then perish.
Oh my god, I did it.
Unlock Shadow Rifle.
What the fuck is Shadow Rifle?
Oh, whoops.
And not...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
It's the game with a fun no no no no no the fun ends here
the fun ends here the fun ends here
It ends it ends it ends I'm stopping the ride right now
Alright guys that was an adventure It truly was an adventure
playing Shadow the Hedgehog.
This was the one Sonic game that I've always wanted to play
a Cowling.
Yes, we got the true ending.
Like I said, guys, if I have, if I have too much love for
this game, then like, then it's not good.
Like, too much is a bad thing, you know?
I want to keep, you know, I want, I won't.
You can't have too much of a good thing, guys.
Then you would get Then you'll get overloaded with too much
love.
Yeah, too much edge and you'll get cut.
Exactly, exactly.
All right, I had a fun time going through Shadow the
Hedgehog and seeing where all the memes come from,
basically.
Yeah, we can't be too parasocial with Shadow, guys.
We gotta distance, gotta give ourselves some space.
you know so our love can still keep going um anyway like I
said this was the one game I've always wanted to play and um
and I'm glad to experience shadow the hedgehog with all of
you guys I've never played this game before but I have heard
all the stories all the stories about shadow the hedgehog so
it's great experience it for the first time, blind with all
of you guys, and see all the memes and everything that came
with it.
Um, um, honestly, don't know how I just never got a sequel
or remastered.
I mean, it's, it was already perfect.
Uh, don't know why.
Um, anyway, I'm gonna head off now.
I will be gone for three days because I need to reset
myself.
I've been extremely like social battery very low lately the
last two, three weeks because I've been doing a lot of
collabs.
Like all back to back to back to collabs recently in the
last three weeks.
So I will be taking Sunday, Monday, and Tuesday off.
Why are we back on Wednesday?
Hey guys.
I'm going to head off now.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up.
to get that blood flow interview sale for me head to bed cuz
you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye